all right and we are live
the last word with lord cognito and he
bounces
back on that friday morning flow it's
been a minute man
it's been a minute since we talked it's
been a minute since we've done an early
show it's been a minute so just
just been us yeah what's going on e how
you been man uh
been good been busy um work is still
you know kind of doing its thing but
like for outriders and destiny trying to
keep track of both and then
the internet blew up with like patch
changes and stuff but i've just been
having a lot of fun with outriders and
we'll talk about like
worry like the changes and stuff but
it's been
really refreshing playing that with just
some of the potential that's in there
the fun and it's like i'm not gonna say
it's a perfect game but
right it's like it has been it's just
been a lot of fun and it's felt really
good
um it's just been one of those where i
haven't even hardly
like i made a lost sector video once
but it hasn't but it really hasn't been
that much like i feel you
yeah same boat man i've been having a
ton of fun without riders i haven't
been playing i've been playing like
inconsistent like i've had a couple days
where i've played a lot
and then i've been busy a lot so i've
got a chance to play as much as i want
to but
the times i played is literally exactly
what you said just been half of them
absolute ball does the game have some
issues absolutely
but the fun factor for me has still
been very high that allows me to just
say you know what even despite all these
issues or whatever
you know um i'm still having fun but
yeah man it's been good got my techno
bill
going learning things and learning about
eventual things that will happen to said
build but we'll get into that
and then um yeah all my froze oh they
said we're losing cog
yeah i'm breaking up i mean
they said you're you're breaking up and
i'm trying to see like if i could change
servers
i'm trying to figure out where are you
there here let me see if i can do we get
all right all right we got to get me
back they said i got the robot voice too
yep there we go that'll work it
shouldn't be better now i said stop your
downloads
listen man
anyway hopefully i'm back now but um
yeah like i said
it's just been a ton of fun man just
like i said messing around with bills
playing with people at different levels
stuff like that i got got my first
legendaries
i'm all legendary i got the achievement
all legendaries and i got my first
well yeah i call them the one that i
call exotics what are they called
legendaries the ones that would
legendaries are orange or exotics you
say epics are purple
yeah epics are purple light yellow
orange gold pewter
whatever weird you know that color
that's that's the legendary those are
the ones with names and
two or three perks yeah those are i got
all purples and i got this
uh sick um epic helmet
i don't like the way it looks but it is
one of the most survivable
like survivability builds it's crazy
like whatever my health goes down
i get this extra health thing yep it's
like a bag
it looks like an old russian helmet nice
for a techno master but
it's really strong and uh yeah man i've
been having
a a bunch of fun with the game man ton
ton stuff to talk about with this yeah
i was like i think that's where we'll
start honestly because i think that's
what's been
occupying a lot of our time so as for
at least when it comes to the kind of
run-off show as we've been mostly
playing
a lot of outriders i didn't want to
start there because that's been a lot of
the week
we got changes for destiny that are
coming up in the future
um but to start like i've spent my
entire week playing out ryder so we'll
start there we will have time stamps
down below you guys so
if you want to check those out to see
like jump to the destiny stuff or
the outrider stuff so we'll definitely
have those and
um also i want to say for you guys as
well if you watch this on video whether
it's iron lord's podcast or ibantus
youtube channel please drop likes
comments subscribe
follow all those good things you can
find both of us on twitter
and of course you can also find when you
us on audio only take us in your pocket
on your phone on your podcast platform
whether it be spotify
itunes google play like nine other
podcast platforms if you look for us
it's just the lord
or the the last word podcast with
ibontes and lordcognito if you'll just
look up like
ibontis or cognino you're probably going
to find us in the podcast world it's a
pretty
small list so we we out we out here
[Laughter]
so yeah it's like i know last week we
kind of got a little high level in
outriders but now we've had a little
more time into it i've definitely put
some in-game grind in there
uh i just wanted to see where where are
you at in it right now
um yeah first off i actually haven't
really advanced the story much
i'm like level 20.
um i just been taking my time i've been
doing a lot of the side quests
yeah that i have i have i have a
confession oh oh oh
yeah uh so i found that all exploit that
is gonna get nerfed
and um the exploit shout out to elf
boogie that um yeah that i could farm on
the two
legendaries and it is it's like a wild
hunt or something
and you go through all the hunts you go
through the niners eight hunts or
whatever it's
it's one particular one where you go off
and you do the little animation you jump
off to the side
and there's nothing but those um those
enemies prefer alpha perfero
something preferable they look wild
little crazy savage enemies
so you go in there right shout out to
red outdoor because it was re-red
attic we had a couple people doing this
because what what the
that they exploit i don't is it patched
already yeah it's about
oh they got it already i thought the
patch was coming the patch is in
the back end stuff's done where did they
drop the pack
literally yesterday during server
maintenance
sorry y'all this yo it was lit let me
tell you what i was doing
now i can talk for the statues of
limitations up yo all right so what you
could do you go off into the side
and then you kill the boss right
it's a lot of it's very hard encounter
you kill the boss and then he
automatically drops two legendaries and
then what would happen is then you let
the rest of the ads kill you
rinse and repeat when you say
legendaries do you mean epics
whatever the purple one is i'm talking
to destiny
you got to keep them different well it's
up to them to name that the thing
more bolder in the ui so i could know
what they are besides the color
they call them purple purple things
purple drinks purple
two purple drinks and and i got an
exotic in there i got i got i got an
orange oh man it's crazy so yeah i was
in there yeah oreo queen dakota
i think that was the name so yeah you
you once you rough her up
then you get two of the legendaries and
it keeps
you keep doing just rinse and repeat
purples so what happens is the only
thing that slows up the farm is because
of the server
issues that once you rinse or repeat one
person out of your three
bank group goes gets kicked the
dashboard then you wait for that person
that was the multiplayer that was the
multiplayer stuff yeah
you go all the way back yeah i will say
those types of things are supposed to be
fixed for
cross play so the patch is coming for
those so
you know given shot these are two
simpsons two sips of that lead that
purple drink i'm telling you
it was the i iced out my whole character
i got this crazy build with toxic rounds
as a techno man sir
i like i said i had exactly that gave me
that also probability
which i also got there i got with
extreme stuff ability yeah you know
what up so um yeah it was you know it
was nice man so i just stood there for a
while
and then other than the outside of the
exploit i was helping a lot of new
people so um
okay my cousin he got out writers or the
series acts i tested cross play for a
bit
still some issues there but console
playstation 5 to xbox series x was very
good
nice i didn't even realize i could
enable voiceover ip which i need to test
and me and you
well we can't because right now they
they stopped yeah well whenever the
patch goes then
yeah yeah that stuff's supposed to be so
but look overall my final thoughts is
look
i love technomancer that is my favorite
it is so much fun right now
i initially was a turret guy right the
freeze free turret but i've started to
love the cold snap for survivability to
give me a big
chance to breathe blighted on the toxic
rounds for extra dps
and then um i love being support healer
so i'll use the what is it the fixer
wave or whatever it's called yeah
yeah i'm looking at my my teammate's
health okay he's low they'd be like yo
[ __ ] i need to heal
boom throw the heel up so yeah it is the
volkswagen i like that gamma yeah it
does kind of
well from a support it has some things
but it it's it's really
i can't believe how much fun it in the
last point i'll say
i'm in most games even destiny i don't
use sniper rifles i really don't
this game i love snipers oh i really
love i got this um
what you can't say so like i got this
sniper right
it's a bolt one if you're a wizard by
the way the warlock's a pyromancer
not a technomancer probably so but i
haven't tried power with so i can't
like your wizard mage is pyromancer for
sure there's something about the healing
though but anyway
so the bolt action one so what it's only
like five in the clip but the cool thing
is
anybody i wound they get frozen
so while i'm reloading i'm good you know
it's just this great
synergy the last thing besides this
diaper
they have some of the best mod and perk
and variant combination you can take any
i'm sitting at that
what's my man with the glasses to do
with the dude the little you know the
good you go
dr zahidi be that's my man i go over
there i'll be like all right i got this
i'm going to take this model put it here
i'm going to change the variant here
it's so much customization with the most
miniscule things is so i love the
minutia that that's the part of
outriders i love and again one more
point well i'm going off i don't talk
about believe me but won't shut up
either
bro quality of life
it's so good i got all these purples
yeah
click the button you know we got all
these blues you want to get rid of oh
click the button organize
right ui hey you open the chest of the
field i don't got to run out there i
press down on the d-pad
all the stuff comes to me it's just
destiny yo
quality of life you need to learn from
these guys they got that down
we'll get into the negative but i want
to talk about the positive first now
what about you you i know you want
expedition team six wait where you at
you
you don't beat the game five times well
yeah uh
for me i got to i soloed a challenge
tier 13.
um so world tier while you play the
story is one set of tiers
challenge tiers are when you get to the
end of game expeditions
and the level goes up so challenge to
your 13 is enemy and gear level 48
and if you go world tier 15 in the story
that stops at world
at your gear level and enemy level 42 so
it starts to escalate a little bit more
um expeditions are timed i mean my
thoughts about those kind of
they're a cool farm but no that's before
i go too much farther that's the piece
for me
that makes the game fun and that's why
for a lot of people if i could tell them
the demo doesn't do this thing
enough justice at all it's like i sat
there and i looked at i was like okay so
i farmed for a little bit i saw like one
or two legendaries drop while i spent my
crazy amount of time farming the demo
but i saw a couple mods and then i knew
in my head i was like okay
because i know i'm gonna be able to
break this down combine this and that
here make my jigsaw puzzle piece of a
character
and when you put all the different mods
together you want you're like wow this
stuff starts to get really powerful
because you can move it around like you
get one you get one ability of like
if you really want to go and like max
out like you're epic you could put like
six mods for one ability and like
this thing is insane and it's yes and
it's so
it's so crazy and over the top and yet
you can still die trust me oh yeah
absolutely um
and it's just that level of as you said
the customization is fun
it's like they didn't go too they went
new
you can go very nuanced and deep i will
say with like you can make really deep
synergistic builds yes but i feel like
it's
not it's not so like
to it's not decimal fraction percentage
it's not division
fraction it's not that like you will
still have like [ __ ] percentage stuff
like that that's there so you will have
some numbers but
i still feel like it's like it's broader
and bigger
in a weird way than division was i don't
know if it's just the specific abilities
but there's
there's like here there's one mod so
like as the technomancer
it's called tool of destruction you
either pull out a rocket launcher
which sadly needs a buff because it
doesn't hold up yeah i don't like that
or you pull out a minigun
yeah and the minigun and so here's
there's just two mods alone
one mod when you pull out the mini gun
you get a
amount of armor that's equivalent to
whether it's your level your anomaly
power or something
i get 150 000 armor when i pull out my
minigun
there's a mod well at my level and
that's the thing
your mods the many of the mods will
scale to
say if it's gear level 48 it does this
versus if it's gear level 30 it's way
down here
so your level of gear like my light
machine gun for example
the fire power yeah guess the number
it's level 49.
jesus guess the number uh
i don't know if i don't know what's your
firepower like what's your firepower on
your gun
how do you mean knowing my five powers
off the top like you the fact that you
know he's producing like i don't even be
remembered okay it's 70
000. jesus that yeah so it's like it's
that
like so they the numbers start to jump
like every level you go from like 42 to
43 you're like
all right 42 is useless 43 to 44. like
the jump in firepower the jump in
armor's not as big but it's still big
but the jumps in firepower
are massive i got questions for you
because i need to learn from the expert
the ambassador here so you said the
jumps in firepower
now my question on like because you're
so far ahead like when you fall in love
with
uh orange when we're gonna i'm gonna i
can't call it exotic or whatever
right can you keep leveling that all the
way with you or is there a limit
no you you can take it all the way it
just gets
very expensive you're able to do it and
theoretically if you
if you'd farmed a lot of expeditions i
could take like a really low
like i have a level nine from like the
demo okay
if i really wanted to and i farmed i
probably could bump one up
i you could theoretically bump it all
the way yes so if there's a legendary
that you got like at level 14 and you're
like
yeah well i out leveled it a long time
ago so i put it in my stash it's sitting
out there
i get to the end game i still haven't
seen another one of those
theoretically yes you could pull it all
the way out okay okay so after you
stash i'll stash those ones that have
really great synergy
anything with the tier three testache in
this game's legendaries your exotics
your
yellowish color put those in your stash
you may get a duplicate which has
multiplied by that if you get a
duplicate
break one of them down right now yeah
now you get the tier three mod to work
with
uh that's nice if you're not doing
multiple characters some
some guns may not really fall into your
playstyle
then you may just break them down for
the tier three mod anyway
okay but yeah you can literally take
like a level five weapon all the way up
to
well i'm not even at 50 yet but you can
take them all the way
okay no good good now i'm because i
wanted i wasn't sure
what to do with it and like i said the
level up part and then i like the fact
that
you know you could you could pick which
mod out of the tiers to i guess to
to swap and then it locks the other one
it doesn't take it away but it just
locks yes
so if you have two mods on anything
weapon or armor if you switch one
the other one's stuck right the main
reason is
that's your that's where some of the
grind comes in because you gotta find
like
you gotta find the perfect combos
especially with armor you gotta find one
of the mods you like
so if you swap the other one in then
you're like so you have to find half of
it which that's like
that's the thing destiny could do like
if you find half you fit
you find that four-fifths roll or
something you could swap one
node and you're like cool but they're
like nope that would take the grind away
because they don't have as much variety
when it comes to these
varieties because that's that's the
attraction i think it's just like i said
it
i i'm actually it's funny i'm pulling an
e i am infatuated with
every armor piece i get yeah and the
guns are great don't get me wrong the
guns have great mods and stuff too
but it's the arm especially to pair it
with the skills
i want to use right so i got one it
gives me more
you know what is it a toxic round up
time or
you know makes the turret last longer
and it or my fixed weight gives a little
invulnerability in this resistance stuff
it
it really starts to play on it and you
you could literally spec out
every single piece to a specific skill
that you love
and have different variants that make it
better like absolutely that's the
yeah that's the part that's crazy and
it's just like the other thing i think
uh judo said it
is um again quality of life one of the
things i was doing i remember i was
speaking to you you say yo my the guy
that i have is kind of like a glass
cannon but if i get you i get you like
yeah
my build is very my my blighted rounds
build specifically was a glass cannon
i've tweaked it now where i've got more
survivability
uh and there's a couple other builds i
was messing around and seeing with all
that other people do but my fir at first
i was like
i was heavy glass cannon so yeah the
thing that's beautiful about the game
is i've never seen a game say yo every
game i play
with it has a skill tree always says
you've got to pay
this amount of resource to respect and
it feels weird to respect at will
it's i i did it like four times
literally last night
i was like let me just mess around
because my buddy had some issues with
his i wasn't playing with him so i was
just sitting there last night kind of
offline watching a couple of people
stream
uh saw chevy working on his stuff he was
like trying to do a tier 15 thing um
and i was just sitting there like all
right let me see what a skill tree looks
like reset it and let me see what this
looks like and went through the middle
tree and i was just like
in game it's like normally you have to
go online to a skill calculator
to see okay what's all you can do that
stuff in game in
game easy boom it feels like i'm getting
away with something that's how
how cool it is but that's like why why
should that be cost prohibitive
it's a good point it actually makes you
question develop a philosophy right
because it's like
what is the mindset to penalize the
player
outright is this is where iron is is
really deep and not getting enough
credit
and we're going to get into the issues
but that the mentality is
more freedom it's more just go out there
and explore now we're going to get into
these nerfs we're going to talk about
them servers
but as far as the game play why
we keep coming back why i keep coming
back is
i just keep thinking about things to
respect now
because of that i had started off
thinking that i like
um the the minds or whatever it is as a
techno man
right and i was building my thing all
for the minds and all the stuff
then i ended up falling in love with the
like i said the toxin rounds
and this vulnerability build so anything
that makes it vulnerable make someone
vulnerable when i have time oh i got a
question though you gotta help me
do toxic bullets stack with toxic rounds
or no
like if i get toxic bullets on a gun so
there's some blighted rounds on a gun
or toxic or using toxic toxins so right
but bullets can have the ability to
apply the toxic effect
right oh but it does it
okay so there's no double if it just
applies the effect and it's a one
okay okay okay got it okay so that's if
you're running blighted rounds you don't
need a gun that does toxic your
wasting mods okay so what i ended up
doing was
i put a gun that that uh puts them in a
vulnerability state and then i have a
suspect
that makes them more fun okay cool cool
cool all right i will say if your
gun if you see this is this is where it
gets crazy um
if you go top tree which is pestilence i
think that's what it's called yeah um
there's a mod that if they are if they
have a toxic applied to them
they also have vulnerable so if your so
if your gun is doing that you're wasting
guys making it vulnerable and then the
taxi grounds are negative
no no like you you're toxic should make
them votable you don't need the gun to
do it
there's a shield that will do that for
you
and then your gun can do other things i
thought i had something else i thought i
had another spec
something about in the vulnerability
status but you may be right i mean it
depends on what you're running if you're
running blinded rounds
and they as you shoot they apply toxic
and they're little bursts everywhere
when they hit
when toxic is on there's also a mod or
there's a note on the skill tree
right when toxic is applied to enemies
so is vulnerable so it hits both at the
same time so
you don't need a gun to do that okay
because it's already done
all right i'm nervous and i'm gonna
respect that model i got more fun stuff
to play with but that's the thing you
can
you're like oh let me move the mod and
have a little bit more fun
all the time like there is yeah some
uh dakota said it in chat bone shrapnel
and perpetu
mobile um like bone shrapnel when you
shoot an enemy and they explode they
explode in a crazy like
shrapnel bomb that they turn into and
then if you kill an enemy with 35
of your magazine or less left you refill
your magazine yes
i saw that one so there's i mean there's
crazy crazy builds and i've literally
mostly messed around with one class
i've been trying to like kind of grind
hard on the in-game see how close we can
get like build up some stuff
uh weapons yeah give me give me favorite
weapon weapon types
give me what what are you feeling like
where would it smg's the shoddys
i mean everything's longer so i mean
i've been going lmgs
i still like my pulse rifle so like the
attack
dude the tactic i just when i was
leveling up i liked the tactical assault
rifle because it was the three shot
burst it was accurate but also like
the dps of the three shot burst seemed a
lot higher than the sharpshooter version
so like the three shot burst still felt
good i kind of let that one go
then lmgs helped with um
lmg's are nice lmgs are nice for the
capacity of the
clip capacity there was a time though i
was just using like
just a sniper with like a what was it 12
bullet clip maybe
okay but it was all with blighted rounds
crazy amounts of crit damages and i was
one or two shotting everybody
and then there's one of the mods on
blighted rounds this is what my build
has been about which i finally
apparently have to switch away from
since all the nerfs
um blighted rounds
if you get a kill while an enemy is
afflicted by toxic
i got 30 and then there's a mod that
does 40 of my ammo back
so i'm never running out of ammo wow
seriously
never running out of ammo so if a sniper
can sit there and you know two shot
somebody
and then the issue is like okay so you
come up to the boss enemy i got to pump
a lot of damage in
all right there's a
don't cost ammo
really okay okay this
this was the blighted round no tier two
this was the blighted rounds build now
recently there's been a lot of things
that have been knocked down
so it's not as strong um but that was my
build for a while it was
it was sniper for literally probably
like half of the game as i was going
through because just
popping heads everywhere and crap tons
of damage and then literally it was the
boss
the final boss fight of the story right
my sniper was just not working long
enough for capacity
gotcha and then one of the world tiers i
told you guys like it was like world
tier 13 i pulled the reward
it's the machine gun i'm still using now
that's what i used to finish the story
but i was stuck in one little area
before you go to the final fight
i couldn't go back and recraft or mod or
anything i was stuck with what i had
i literally haven't even nope gotcha i
couldn't go back without resetting the
story and then having to fight through
stuff again i was like
i want it i'm right here it's like i
just do it yeah so i tried one pull i
got an lmg and i was like oh my god and
it worked so i was like
i've been using that one since and that
one there's like anomaly blades within
six meters
every like four seconds or something
like four anomaly blades drop down
okay well at level 49 each anomaly
blades hit
hits for like 80k
[Applause]
so yeah there's yeah there's there's
some
there's some craziness bro it's it's
it's fun but
it's like just see it now let me ask you
this because we're this is weird
we're both the same class which is weird
yeah i'm not used to this
so has there been any other class play
for you outside of technology i started
a little bit with a devastator
i did i think my wednesday stream was
just like working on a devastator
going through the story now what way
yeah with that deficit how you
how much level like if i'm like i just
finished the snow area i'm not that far
okay
okay what's the devastated feeling like
for you because i heard the word on the
street devastating getting enough love
you know
i was like i mean it was i mean i'm so
i have to switch my mind because the
leeching of the technomancer
always getting healing is a thing you
get accustomed to if you're doing damage
you're getting healing
yield then if you switch over it's all
about the kills now you have some like
life-sapping abilities and stuff like
that which trimmer i opened up which
kind of helped quite a bit
um that's the and that's kind of one
thing that's a very good question to
transition into
is like new characters yes
and get it let's get it anybody who
starts
on outriders basically you don't get a
good feel of what the game's potential
is
until you get to about level 20 you
start seeing the epics
you get lots of mods going into effect
like until you start seeing
like two different mod slots on each
piece of armor you're starting to throw
some cool stuff in there
right you're not seeing what any
character is capable of that's why i was
like
my devastator still is like i'm working
with mostly blues i might have one or
two epics i got an auto shoddy
but nothing is really like really big
working to get nothing's there yeah
i'm guilty of that with power i think i
threw pyro away way too
early and what i'm going to do is
because my cousin got outright is i'm
going to do it
to do a lower level character i'm going
to make a pyro
and um you know what you call play with
him so i could really level it out and
fill it out
i got to shout out trickster about most
of the people i play with tend to be
tricksters for some reason
that was like the common one they're
like the hunters of the of the game yeah
tricksters they they've been putting in
work that that bubble with the then the
spinning thing and then those rounds
which are about to get nerfed
but that like they're doing some serious
dps out here so i
that that's my experience seeing them i
haven't run with a pyro or pl
no what i play with tends to be
pyromancer so i wanted to see what that
high-level pyromancer play is
yeah i saw it was just like a screenshot
and i think it was t-rex and fallout
were playing together and i think t-rex
was probably carrying fallout
um just you know he probably just got a
little bit more time i think followed
was working on something he jumped into
outriders a little
later um but when he jumped in like you
saw the damage difference and it's like
this will happen but i was like
depending on if you're pulling something
through if trx does 50 million damage
during the course of an expedition and
then fallout does 5 million damage
and trx was the pyromancer you know it's
doing something
and i see the thing that is like fallout
was probably under leveled so that's
a level two but still i think yeah yeah
no i was just gonna say pyromancer has
potential
is all the thing that i think tassie
said or someone said that
it's very intriguing to me is i i
wouldn't know because they saying like
the power manchester can
interrupt bosses and my thing is a lot
of times you fighting those captains or
whatever
and they doing this health regen and
they're doing all this and i want to be
able to stop that so if the pyro can do
that all of the classes
even the technomancer can our blighted
rounds build can't that's the
i thought the vulnerable difference
would do it and yeah they said all of
those just they take 30
more damage right who knows it was 25
now it's 15. that got nerfed as well
okay vulnerable got nerfed and two mods
got nerfed from 30
so yeah the change is like vulnerable is
less effective
and then for the technomancer build that
i had one mod used to do 30
crit damage now it's 15. anoth one other
skill tree node used to do 30
damage to toxic enemies now it does 15.
all three of those added up
my damage is like 40 percent less that's
insane that hurts
so we got nothing what as for the
technos
the rocket launcher will do it the
shrapnel bomb will do it the paint the
the
artillery launcher will do it like the
one that you drop it's like
the wave of rockets oh that little short
one that you just put on the ground yeah
and it's like a
quick burst
like all of those that's the thing so
those are the interrupt skills
yeah those are the things if you select
the skill it will say
like the word interrupt gadget and
interrupt
it'll actually tell you if it's capable
of interrupt and that was the thing with
the build is like i was just going pure
damage
i couldn't interrupt either so i'm
always trying to dodge all the skills or
if they pop shields i can't do anything
about it
and that was the thing with the build if
you have interrupts like gravity leap
you jump in the air and go smash
somebody that's an interrupt
got you so there are benefits to other
classes
and benefit benefit to the interrupt
ability because that
allows you to stop them from doing all
that crazy boss stuff that they'd be
doing
all right i'm learning i'm in school
with the ambassador man i'm in school
with e right i'm learning
learning deep level play well gmd is
that what do you tell those that play
out writers for the first time
get to level four or five and say it's
not their thing i think
fun i uh it gets fun at
level 45 and amazing the further you go
up especially if you're grouped with
buds that's
that's the thing is like in the demo you
didn't get to see crafting at all
you get to see a you know dystopian
wasteland which you even said you're
like i don't want to see just the
desert area like spoiler alert for you
guys but i'll just give you biomes
you've got like the sahara version of a
desert you've got
the forest enclaves you've got snow
um you've got these like cool temple
areas with like
awesome like kind of alien architecture
there's some cool areas to the game
oh yeah it's not all like the dystopian
city from
it's not just the dim there's there's
more and it's like
it's really hard it's not it's trying to
tell somebody's like hey you need to get
to episode eight
right in a season be like the first four
or five episodes are good like i've
i've been slowly working through the
animated series the clone wars and like
some people like series one and two i'm
like yeah they're not bad they're kind
of cool i don't mind people are like
from like three on
it's like that's where it really starts
to build i hear because you get like a
couple different characters come into
play
and then you can take that into rebels
and like it's really good from there but
the first couple season the clone wars i
guess it was trying to find its footing
not a fine footing and it's like it's
been slow for me to get through
a little bit but it's like eventually i
guess if i hit three it's just gonna
roll
um yeah but and it's kind of one of
those it's like
if you can take a minute and just
imagine
some of the combinations of the modding
the like now you get two of each mod so
like instead of having five armor mods
you now have ten
like double stacked and then each of the
weapons and then you have weapons that
do like lightning damage and i have one
now
if i get a crit kill it's a bulletproof
bubble just appears
seriously they go crazy with it man
that's the part about it i love they
really go crazy but it's like you said
it's like you know you got to stick with
it
playing with friends is fun i have to
make it oh really i've done
yes uh he's slowly been working through
he was doing the devastator and
unfortunately like for
he picked a hard class yeah like he
picked a tough class so it was like
he changed he'd like to take he think
he's going to take a tank he's like and
he kind of feels like he's stuck in that
one so i've got to figure out a build
that works for
leveling up i got tremor which helps
because it's this little earthquake that
kind of sucks health from like four or
five enemies around you every so often
then if you can get some kills but i was
like i will say as a devastator just
running around
before i was just like i went through
and blinded around like nuked everything
it did it was i mean i get that was op
while you're leveling up
it's not it's not op in the endgame
because i got to a point where we were
like we were trying
but it is like it was still tough
and there are other builds that
apparently are more powerful as you
level up it's faster
so you may crutch it for a while but
there's other things that can work
but yeah it's like for the devastator i
definitely had to kite guys a little
more and kind of be a little more like
elusive because when it gets to like a
boss into me and that's what i always
notice like the technomancer was good
against bosses
yeah constant leeching is keeping you
alive you're a little bit of a little
bit of health a little bit of health a
little bit all the time
i love that mentality to keep killing
keep
shooting otherwise that that's what
that's my essence of the bill continue
i was like and the difference is like
most of the other classes the pyromancer
you gotta mark and then if they die
the other two would just kill up close
and you get like 24 of your health back
so if you kill two or three guys like
half your health or more like you get
chunks of your health that are massive
and you can even improve your healing
received which by the way if you have
anything that says healing received it
does you no good as a techno answer
really pretty much unless you use like
the healing ability because
the healing received is like from big
heels
it's not from leeching so
considered leeching huh as a
technomancer what we're doing is
considered leeching yeah we're leeching
out we're slowly like slapping it away
right right right oh i didn't know that
not seeing him yeah so the healing
recipe
if you see that on armor it's not doing
anything for your leeching board
yeah protect no matter okay god she got
you okay okay
i got some stuff to change that's what's
up
so we gonna get into these uh these
patches and uh yeah we'll go through the
goodness get into the bed
um so patch news first and they are
working on a date they're hoping
uh basically a week or so they're trying
to get a
schedule currently scheduled for next
week um they don't have a specific date
of like here's the date for the patch
because honestly they can drop these
things anytime
destiny is very much on its tuesday
cadence for like reset and everything
this is just like here it is
yeah they're just here they're out here
uh so patch notes these are first
they're going to be doing a lot of like
little minor improvements but the big
ones
once platforms have been updated to the
same patch version cross-play across
platforms will become available again
so they're claiming that that will be
their overall stability improvements for
the matchmaking service as well
crash pictures yeah crash fixes
uh we'll fix a multiplayer clock uh
crash that could lead the cl
result in client players having their
inventory wiped this is a big one that
happened to a friend of mine
oh so wait wait wait
what's the wipe what's going on a
multiplayer crash can wipe your
inventory
yo that's me that's bad that's bad
and and we let's we got to talk about
this because i mean
we've been bloviating about how great
this game is
and it's fun and it's addicting but i
gotta say
this is probably the most unstable
worst server game i have ever played
yeah i've done so much solo like if you
play solo you haven't seen that much
what multiplayer i've heard is wrong
i literally have not gone a day without
and i'm talking about crashes to
dashboard oh i know
it it it just it's bad bro like
now get if this game wasn't this beloved
and this
fun it would be getting dragged oh
that's how that tells you how fun it is
that people work through these bugs but
yeah it's like
the inventory wipe now they're working
on a recovery piece for that as well so
they are trying to get that going for
people
so if it happens to you it's not a live
service games give it some time
try maybe another character i get that
that sucks
they said your blues and stuff probably
won't come back but the epics and the
legendaries for wipes should be coming
back
what oh no believe me and it was
something that happened in the demo
and they lowered the number of times it
happened a lot it's like they
drastically lowered it
but still apparently been happening
enough but they should say that fix
should be there
certain mission launches uh one of the
side quests was crashing
um so those were going to be there they
said fix the hud disappearing um i know
one of my buddies another friend of hid
disappeared yeah
i disappeared in the military i'm i'm
going off muscle memory and animation of
the character okay my round my toxic
rounds up
okay okay i think i think the heel is up
there like what is going on yeah so i
mean there's some weird bugs that happen
and they've happened to
a lot of people these are all supposed
to be coming in the first patch
which is not bad that they're hitting a
lot of big stuff in
two weeks but they are big enough that
it's like
those hurt a lot like could you have
waited two weeks for this
if this could be done in two weeks
april 1st april 15th i mean everybody
filed their taxes and then played on the
16th i don't know
um that's kind of the thing it's like
and this is the whole thing about any on
like you have like all your testing in
the world then the minute it's live more
people played it than you ever have
whatever quote that was i saw somewhere
i heard somebody else say it recently oh
yeah
you have more testing that ever happens
it's like
i don't know if they're just like pot
committed to a date or if it's like if
we know this is a thing
maybe they needed more people to see it
happen unfortunately to like narrow down
the bug like
we need a bigger qa like sample size to
understand what's happening
right i don't know but it's like yeah
some of the that's and that's
unfortunately a thing it's like two or
three weeks later
if this stuff is right have people
falling off i think a lot of people have
had fun
the inventory of one would kill you fast
like you'd be like
especially if you're like i made it to
like level 20 i got a couple legendaries
it's all gone
what the hell yeah that would ruin
anybody's fun
and i still got gotta say the elephant
in the room though
because it's like okay i get it you know
some some issues can't be replicated
until
the whole thing is live and you get a
true idea of server load and stuff like
that
the only problem that i'm a little
concerned with them is
is that what should be paramount
is server stability crashes and fixes
right yeah the only issue from the
optics right now
is that we're one week into the game
and they've got this huge nerf list
about what they're going to balance in
the mountains i'm just getting there i'm
not even there okay
okay because i'm about to go there i'm
like that's my only thing
trust me
i know you popped off too soon
um you know players stuck in geometry
replaying multiplayer extensions they
also said matchmaking is gonna be set to
close
instead of open by default so if you
don't remember that it's just always
closed you can open it up
they're gonna say many other fixed
improvements for pc specifically for me
will fix a performance issue where gpu
is not being
fully utilized this should help the
stuttering in directx 11 and 12.
this i've been waiting on so thank you
for that
that's what's like i want this patch for
me next week one for cross play
two for that fix so we gotta cross play
um so the next please piece they're
talking about is just multiplayer
stability
um they're talked about that a little
bit but just the fact that crossplay
should be getting
like all the multiplayer stuff should be
vastly improved once this goes live
hopefully next week they're working on
so
cross play multiplayer stability pc
stability bug fixes like for major
things like that a lot of that stuff is
coming pretty quick
and i don't know if they just needed two
weeks to finish the patch and they could
have waited to launch it or if they
needed two weeks for a lot of people to
see it
and then they could narrow down where
the errors were actually happening i
don't know
if it's six of one half dozen of another
but sucks they were happening but still
that's a thing
as for the inventory wipes and
restoration they do have a specific word
on that
so i want to touch on that in case it
has happened to anybody just to let you
guys know
while it opens slowly uh basically they
say restoration should take place on a
specific day and it'd be a one-time
event
so they're trying to basically get
everything lumped in
the exact date is to be coming but they
hope it to be occurring in the coming
week weeks
so like a week or two okay uh they'll
update the timings
they said they'll be able to store most
valuable tiers of lost items epics and
legendaries they're unlikely able to
store
all blue gear okay um but they're still
should be able to get and that again
you're probably gonna be okay without
those you'll get crap tons of those
restorations should be additive to your
inventory should not replace your
inventory so they're going to put it
back
in if you still keep playing uh restored
items may not have the exact same stats
as lost items could be slight variations
but
that's not bad i mean it sucks that it
happens at all believe me it's like
that's a really crappy bug to even ship
with like
that one the fact that it was still
there when it shipped and i was like
i thought i didn't know because i
honestly didn't hear much and then
like i'd heard like one they said it was
like really small and minor just a few
circumstances
and then it literally happened like one
of my best friends and i was just like
and he was with me at lake challenge
tier 13 in the end game he was like 48.
and he's like i don't even have a pistol
like
everything like it was bad so
that was about that's one of those where
it's like this one can ruin some people
like and this is where again what is the
percentage of people it's affected by
how do you make that call but that one
like if somebody's like don't play the
game i lost my inventory you could like
that's a bad one to hear it's a snowball
right yeah so that one can be like
don't touch the game until this is fixed
type thing that kind of hurts
yeah neil mental asks even equipped
items to happen
uh i mean he had no pistol equipped
it was yeah it hit a couple equipped
things too a lot of people was like
mostly inventory so if you had stuff in
there he still had a couple things but
no they lost a lot
um so multiplayer they're continuing to
work on multiplayer stability connection
that's there but
not to make you wait too long now we can
talk about the balancing
so general notes they had the historian
bounty hunt and
monster hunt quest no longer grant
legendary items for each subsequent
completion
okay players who took advantage of this
exploit will not be punished but there
was an exploit and this is why now this
is what takes a lot of people off
you can go what the normal way i don't
know i didn't actually do your exploited
didn't know about it until this came out
i see yeah you're one of those you broke
it
if you when you get to a certain point
in the story you get to a certain town
you talk to a couple vendors and they
open up these things called hunts and
targets they're
hunting monsters and then killing
targets right
they're in like almost every zone so you
go through and you'll have like
10 of them to do well you can go through
do all 10 of the monster hunts go back
to that vendor
and your reward for completing all ten
was
one legendary if it was the target if it
was the targets
it was one gun if it was the monster
hunts it was one piece of armor
right you were apparently getting now
you said epics
it was purple you were getting purple
purples i did
get it my first epic though in that same
form but everything was it was two
purples
every time yeah yep there was two
purples every time we did that
okay like that's not that you weren't
even doing the exploit then you were
just like
you were doing what people were doing in
the demo they would go up kill a captain
die and have him respawn so they could
kill the high level guy over and over
yeah that's honestly just like farming
that's already been in there like that's
not even an exploit
apparently that's that's safe yeah you
could do that still
probably i heard i so i think it's
random someone told me that they they
nerfed
they nerfed that thing that we were
doing i was like maybe
like maybe some of that stuff's been
changed too like historian bounty hunt
monster hunts no longer great legendary
but the legendaries like the tier three
level items people were
exploiting those oh the gold okay yeah
and that's the one
i think um with the sword adjustment we
want to eliminate this exploit behavior
while still making that quest line worth
the effort and that's the
unfortunately the question is and i'm
still looking for clarification because
if you go through all
10 and you don't get one legend it takes
you a little while
yeah yeah people at the end game can go
like farm
like you can do high challenge tiers and
get like you know a couple legendaries
like
yellow ones potentially so they'll be
able to do it faster but if you could go
through like 10 different hunts
maybe at least like build up your
repertoire work on some of your
duplicates
that was a nice thing that was still
there i'm still waiting for
clarification if that's like
if the tin still doesn't work sorry
uh they adjusted loot on specific
enemies these particular beasts are
being too generous
considering the effort required to kill
them so this could have been one there's
two could be split two sand shift or a
cold claw
i guess certain enemies were giving more
loot than normal
some of this stuff won't affect you yeah
but some of it definitely will so
champlain and boomtown they're two of
the expeditions they
lowered the top like all the expeditions
are timed so gold
silver bronze they have a certain time
for you to qualify the faster you do it
the better
chance at higher rewards like if i do a
gold tier
tier 10 or something i get like three
percent chance at a legendary on a
couple of the drops
yep so now you have to do some of them
faster i had
one where like i went through and i
almost had the gold solo like it was
probably could have just been a little
faster and had it
right after all the nerfs i barely had
bronze
damn that's how much they hit my build
oh but also they lowered the time but it
also lower the time
and that's i guess the issue we'll get
into a little bit more but it's like
that stems from two sides of a nerf is a
little much at the same time
and that's what we'll get into in a
second so keep that in the back of your
head so
but it was only two the other hunts
times are still or the other
expeditions are still the same are still
the same so just those okay just those
two
i guess people were like burning through
them doing them quickly i like kim town
didn't seem bad for a solo player
there were people who had broken build
like somebody was like oh i was doing
this thing in like five minutes i was
like
apparently my build's not that efficient
um so then a couple changes critical
rating damage multiplier on tactical
assault rifles
reduced to 165 percent was 175
critical rating multiplier on marksman
rifle reduced from 250 percent
uh was 300 so basically just the crit
damage on certain things were too high
and again that was literally going into
my build everything was all about like
the crit multiplying over and over and
over
and those two just had the highest crit
on top so they were
they're bringing those down as well they
got they got you
pretty much and this is where it comes
in so bullet abilities twisted arounds
blinded rounds volcanic rounds
they said while we fully intend to
provide the overpowered feel for the
best builds out there
we are also committed to making sure
there is build diversity at the top
performing builds
and this is where i have a question for
him late in the demo life cycle
and again listen to the timing we
discovered a bug with regards to bullet
augmentation abilities damage
calculation formula while we fixed this
bug some unforeseen
imbalances were unfortunately introduced
which has led bullet-based abilities to
vastly outperform other skills the main
problem with this
is that bullet-based builds require much
less investment to make them top tier
compared to other builds to achieve this
we made a couple adjustments
for the trickster and technomancer
classes who benefit the most from their
bullet abilities
it's uncertain as to whether these
changes will prove too strong or too
weak
so please do consider this to be only
the first step as we will continue to
monitoring and adjusting them in the
future
just like you hope to see more inspiring
crazy combinations of abilities and mods
so while the theory's right right some
of the chunks are just big
like i already said like what they i
lost three things
that dropped like an addition of like
hey this mod's half is good this month's
half is good this month's
thirty percent is good those start
adding up or like yeah
my crit values are much smaller i am a
lot weaker than i was
when it's all combined together so the
base cooldown for twisted rounds has
been increased into 25 seconds
um while infinite uptime on bullet
abilities is always our intention
which isn't a bad thing right so that's
actually cool the infinite uptime bullet
abilities
actually they're okay with that it is
intended to be high risk high reward
playstyle
however given the current power of the
skill there's very little risk involved
in this
ability giving it short cooldown even
when players fail to trigger ammo and
replenishment
increasing its cooldown it was 16
seconds now it's 25.
yeah see i will definitely say like the
cool down for the technomancer the
blinder downs it takes forever like if
you mess up my build
and the blinder rounds go away i am like
screwed i guess the tricksters was a
little shorter
yeah because i always felt the the
techno dancer it
took a while for that cool down like you
know i mean to cycle
i i've always felt that but trickster
this hurts because my boy red
he's a trickster man in it this was he
he was in love with that build he was
doing so much work and now
it's increased to 25 seconds and we're
gonna continue because we still got more
so the tricksters a couple of tree nodes
disruptive firepower
scion of power outrider executioner have
had their power reduced to 35
previously 50. so three different nodes
went from 50 down to 35.
so again you're starting to see where
the vulnerable status so it was 25
and that's for every single class this
is all the same thing just that power is
reduced to 15 percent
why because they put it in a lot of
places that stacked with these builds
it's literally because of that
technomancer damage against poison had
its power reduced to 15
previously 30 percent and then what's
not even mentioned here
there's one of the armor mods also had
his crit damage reduced
damn like that's not even listed that's
why so vulnerable
the node and then one of the armor mods
which were all part of the build
all got reduced basically in half let me
read this part with the technomancers
blighted round
while the technomancers blighted around
do not provide any damage increase on
their own
other than ignoring armor as anomaly
damage they do provide an excellent tool
for spreading the vulnerable and toxic
statuses
which in turn can scale out of
proportion so that was that part
that when they get hit with the toxic
round the other enemies around them also
get the status effect
yeah are they trying to control group
people getting into that group well they
just thought it was too strong because
basically you would affect vulnerable to
groups
right they thought vulnerable was too
strong because like you'd hit one guy
i could shoot one guy eight people were
vulnerable right
so the spread was strong but again that
was part of the build i can tell you i
didn't feel like broken now some people
with apparently like
you know the sharpshooter machine gun
we're just like literally clicking heads
and apparently going crazy with it but
i wasn't there yet so it kind of sucks
to see mine but apparently some people
had some busted versions of it
um and one of the top replies they say
i'm a techno while i felt strong i
didn't feel broken
i felt uh pyro and technomancer needed
some love so there's two pieces of this
uh the other one the other highest voted
comment you need to rebalance enemies
too
hello so this goes into the full
combination of what it's like for the
end game
of how does it feel
when you take people and they're
leveling up some people are going to be
at the end game these are your like one
percenters not most you're not even
there yet
right that's my thing and most people
aren't even there it's like yeah your
one percenters are farming like crazy
well okay that's fine but on the other
side you take
like as i said mine it took like three
different things got hit basically in
half
so you take those multiplication the
multiplication
the multiplication yeah multiplicative
you take that effect on mine and you
start dividing it down the other
direction now it starts to really
whittle that number down
oh yeah this stacks and then it's like
okay so you do that and then just the
weird like
knife turn is like why would you make a
couple of the expeditions
have to be faster yeah i was like and i
was actually watching chevy shout out to
him i mean he
threw my technomancer under the bus in a
comment but you know everybody has their
opinions but on the other side it's like
he's like
they didn't incentivize other
ones they just said don't play these two
just don't do that yeah don't do this
this is too fast
it's not like hey these you know we're
going to give a little more generosity
here to spread it around you can do them
all that way
no we're going to lower these two down
yes i'm with you
and to me the biggest indictment where
they need to be careful
is oh they they one week into launch
one week the meta hasn't even settled
didn't like
this percent that's using this like
they're so afraid that i guess this is
going to go out like wildfire and it's
like let it sit like
i'm not eve i'm playing a lot but i'm
not even you know
30 or whatever it is i'm like in the 20s
and i'm playing fairly decent but
it's like calm down because my thing is
at the end of the day if you getting
shout out to slow mo backs that's my
homie he's a big division guy
division guys were reading this oh they
were like that sounds exactly
yup yup they were like up people could
fly it out ronnie's taking the page that
and again it's early i'm not going to
indict them all the way yet
but they've got to be careful because
the key point is what you said
it never feels good when it's just like
okay don't do that don't do that stop
stop stop stop
where is the in we got to give bungie
this
where is the incentive for another style
to come up
right and that's the other thing they
didn't buff anything else
like it's right let's bring this stuff
down
a lot like right these are multiple
two or three mods per class that you're
knocking off basically to say hey
these are too strong let's lower one of
these down
you know that's like let's take
vulnerable status and move that from 25
to 15 let's make these things instead of
30 let's make them 25 no it's literally
half half
half half and then here's the thing
let's be real like again they i
worried a little this is a pve
only exactly like bro we are supposed to
have fun
the strength of why we love this game
is we are having fun with crazy bit
why are we worried like what are we what
are we doing there's no other
player versus player component so why
the fear why
do they feel like everyone's going to do
this and the game's going to be done do
you not have content lined up
like why are you i mean you know
that's what i i saw i was gonna get this
i was gonna get there because it's like
why are you gatekeeping so early one
weekend to launch
and i'm just like well it's like okay so
i played for 50 60 hours of what stupid
amount i played so i haven't even looked
i probably shouldn't
um yeah i've played a lot and my buddy
and i are there and he
burns through games we both got up there
fairly high but what we were doing is
two
blighted around machine gun tectomancers
we got through 13 and we like squeaked
out gold on one of them by a second and
it felt good
good like 14 like he tried it like 13
solo like i told you i was hovering
right almost to gold if i was a little
more pushy i probably could get there
he tried 14 he's like dude i can't even
get i can't even stay alive
so we didn't feel broken now there are
a higher echelon even beyond like me who
blade 60 my buddy's like ultra efficient
like every game he plays he doesn't care
about story just blows through it and
like always goes for efficiency
right like there's gonna be us who were
like we were close but like 13
feeling good squeaking out some golds
like it felt
so right good yeah and then it's like
you do this and i'm like i
literally went from almost gold and some
like solo golds
to literally bronze oh i feel you and
listen i rarely play this game solo but
what i tend to do is i tend to do side
quest stuff solo
just to get a feel of how my build
actually works by myself right
and there was just one mission you
probably know what mission i'm talking
about it's not even for you it's
probably laughable for me this thing was
terrorizing me right
it was just one mission where they were
like um
this religious cult and they were acting
like shamans yeah
so that mission was tearing my old
technomancer build
up that was what i was going in there
with um the turret
and i think i was going in there with
the rocket or the tools of destruction
or whatever right
yeah wasn't working i was getting lashed
it so then i came in there with a new
build held
the the uh the toxic rounds and then i
had some uh the cold snap i debuted it
and it goes like you're supposed to be
off altered yeah we are supposed to be
so it's like and all this new stuff
and survivability and i'm sitting there
beating the bosses and i'm like but i'm
tactical i'm like
just it was just a perfect synergy and
i'm feeling strong i'm like yo this
build is good
and it felt good to solo it and i was
just like man
that's a feeling i didn't have like i
like this you know say this really feels
like a good feeling so it's like
now when they encourage the nerfing of a
specific play style
you've got to push the player in another
direction besides just taking that
and you know saying taking that
completely away from and that's what i
worry about because it's like
as a pve only game
you've got to you got to be careful to
make your player base
not feel like yo you're handicapping us
yo you're taking the fun away
because it gets it gets dangerous and
that's why i was just worried
about content i'm worried about okay
now that you know eventually the pla the
base will get to where you are
and when they get there like i want the
game to succeed i wanted to stick around
and i'm just my concern is long-term
okay what's gonna happen i don't think
it's an
anthem situation no i don't think it's
that because i
everything you described about the
expedition still sound fun the timing
the loot all that stuff they're still
doing a thousand things better than all
the other two
but i am worried now what happens
once people get there you know what are
they gonna do especially if they're
going down this route and not
encouraging other other bills but what
do you think about life i mean
you know now that you're currently there
up until right now they've been doing
literally everything right now i will
give them props the communication
has been stellar oh yeah the
communication like talking about it even
giving like their reasons as to why
fine ish um but like
during the demo hey we took like the
legendaries at a chest okay we put the
chest back for the boss fight so if you
want to farm him
you can still farm side quests the
captain still they didn't take anything
too far yeah they need to remember the
bulk of us are not the glads of the
world and that's the big thing
division did this like you said it but i
remember like it was
like division tech or whatever one of
those little resources and pete
streamers had this like they were
starting to farm it really readily and
they were going to start farming it up
and they
knocked it down for them what does that
do for the average player now they have
crap
just they have very hard ways to get
that specific resource
same and it's like no it's just and
catering to
that those people literally are crazy
for a reason
i think i know what to do i'm guessing
but my
my theory is the ibantis is the glass
and you guys make the video i'm not on
his level
but you know what i mean when you make
your bills right the vibe i get
is they are worried about joe blow or
joe casual
looking at your guys videos and then
it's spreading and disseminating
right i'm not saying it's right because
it doesn't make any sense to target
that smaller percentage when the rest is
not there but it almost seems like now
okay i'm gonna make your video invalid
because that build no longer works
i mean they literally did and that
and again they better pay attention to
division
because i all my division guys when i
speak to them they say
this that disconnect with the fun of the
community
and them trying to put a figure in the
damn to stop something and it's like bro
let them have fun now granted glitches
exploits
yeah that stuff but i was like i farmed
a demo for i farmed a dumbass demo for
60 hours because of the potential that
was there because it felt cool
i was like we were farming this stuff
and even if i got to like 15
i still have a build to work on i still
would want to get legendaries i still
got to unlock the tier 3 mod to combine
it into another mod
i still need to do these things and
people can do like you can do a
challenge to your
15 expedition you may not get a
legendary that's not even a guarantee so
like
just the fact that you can run those
it's supposed to be a diablo thing
diablo showers your butt with like thank
you
loot like crazy and they i mean
they make the the sponginess is crazy
the shields that come up you got so many
more elites now i'm getting teleported
around the map with spinning lasers of
there's a lot of crap going on and i can
tell you like 99.5
of the people never felt broken they
felt like they were having fun
and that is why this game was so good
yes
that's why people love the uh my thing
is you're they're saying
they're not live service so in my
opinion
your diablo your third person diablo
yeah right that's literally what it is
brace the fun that's why diablo guys
love it they got they get all crazy they
get the
all the armors all these bills all these
strats and then you know there's the
world tears you you up it up
let them have fun what what are you
worried about like well you don't say
like it's
too early to i'm monitoring them
monitoring
and the other side you said it too is if
you're gonna bring something down
if this is this strong where is the
other classes
where is the anomaly power that doesn't
match because it's the reason of
firepower being that strong
if my like one bomb goes out and does
this little
bit of damage and i gotta wait for its
cooldown but like and
the way like the way they throw the ads
at you and
in expeditions it's just this like it's
an onslaught of stuff you've gotta fight
and unless like i've got a certain set
of abilities that are doing certain
things and there can be other builds
that work
but i was like you got to make sure that
other stuff is buffed up strong enough
to handle
when they lowered the time on boomtown
right and chevy
is like chevy's right there with glad
they two-man
raids and crazy they do the ridiculous
stuff because
they're at that level if he even says
boomtown which is one of those
they lowered the time on that one
already even a little more he's like
that's just dumb
like i want to see a solo person at
like you know 13 14 15. i want to see a
solo build
do that now i want to see a solo like v
and there's it's like and how many
two three certain build how much
grinding does it take to get to that
build
should you be rewarded when you get
there yeah if you get to the point where
you can actually solo those
that fast and you've made a build that
gets there
what what harm does that do that's what
i'm saying if your build is at that
if your build is at that level you
should be able to do that
now if you go to another build you might
farm to try and make another build
right but if your build is at the
pinnacle this game does have an end
point
you are meant to get to that level of
god tier that's what i'm saying
you're meant to be able to beat every
you're meant to be able to get gold on
everything
if you can get gold on everything guess
what you won the game you won the game
there's a finite end and that's why
that's the thing that's frustrating
they have a finite game that they're
trying to stop that if people are gonna
get there regardless
so so and here's the thing when you have
these videos you have the
the that small percentage of that elite
making that stuff
that gets people to get when you get
people to make content in your game now
you're nerfing that again
they better learn from massive
entertainment whatever them do is from
their division
they better learn because these are the
steps that got
people to say yo i'm out they cause if
you keep doing all right let's it's
early we're gonna give it a pass
we'll see how it goes it's early we we
love this game we think the future
is bright there's a lot to love we're
just
we we've seen history you know and we
you've got examples you've
you're learning you got the um
the ui the quality of life you've got
the you know the legendary epics all
that stuff
you got great builds and post
apocalyptic looks and
all these cool weapons the weapons feel
good the abilities feel good the
monika you got all these things going
for you right
remember why people love your game
because it's fun
you know what i'm saying and we get to
do these cool things you get to feel
powerful
you're literally embracing the thing
that destiny is struggling with yeah
and the people who don't like destiny
are going
to your game for this don't get into
this fun police stuff too heavy
because there will be a mass exodus
quick especially
when your game is finite so that's
that's why i ran on it but yeah i'm glad
you said it man because i really
i really hope as we go on we start to
see
okay we know i want to that's what i
want to see on the patch notes
we started to notice that you know
technomancer users are not utilizing
blah blah blah right and or pyromancers
are not and
you know what we've increased the buff
here on this right now that's
it's that needs to come when this
happens and that's the first mistake
these two those two things needed to
happen together not a weekend
not when your early access streamers
didn't sleep and played the hell out of
the game
for casual joe who has like two hours
every other day to play the game who's
slowly working through the story
and now he's going to hear about this
build he's like started out cool
and now he's it's not going to work
quite the same way it's like
this is too soon without the other side
to balance it
oh yeah oh yeah try to do it he said
where's this firework oh no no we give
bungie that work
when they do it but in fairness like i
said earlier to to bungie
for the most part bungie will do this
they'll hit you with this but they'll
say in the same patch knows we
understand this may frustrate some blah
blah blah
but we're going to show you how we're
going to build this other thing up
to encourage other styles you've got to
give out always
not always no ways but no not always
but some of the time some of the time
this is their first note but i was like
there's plenty of times that bungie's
like
yeah no no no i feel that i feel it i'm
just saying that
at some point i just want to see it i
don't know yeah
you can't say that right never done that
that's all i'm trying to say we can't
have the same situation where bungie's
never no you just never
never said no no no like there's plenty
of times when they've just you know
dropped it dropped a turret into the
past notes and you're just like
okay this sucks like that's what happens
straight up we'll get to that next we
definitely get today
all i'm saying is again one i've never
seen a game
one week into release no that has a
two-story night with no
end game talk about yo we nerf and all
that yo how about you nerf the server
problems
how about we never try and yeah it's
like a thing too is like
hey servers are feeling better we've
gathered a lot of data these things feel
a little strong
these things feel a little weak not like
hey server's coming next week but we're
nerfing this now like
yeah yeah right because that's where i
feel away because the pride
all the priorities should be getting
this game
to be functional yeah as opposed to they
worrying about
other that that's my thing that's my
thing and i get it it's early i'm trying
to be not i like the game you know what
yeah and they
they say important balancing is done by
a separate team to those that are
working on preparing
patches rebalancing does not impact our
progress towards batches so like
of course you have several dreams i get
that it's more of the optics
of the balancing like people have issues
getting in
they don't want to hear about nerfs from
their youtuber their friends or anybody
else like if
and it's not everybody that goes to
youtube like 70
of people probably doesn't even give a
damn about the youtube videos of this
guy's
thing but also it's like for those who
do which typically are the more vocal
and spread words
do you want to see hey this stuff got
fixed awesome multiplayer's working
cross-play
and you could say hey we're looking at
these things if you guys are in these
builds
we are looking at maybe toning these
down they seem like you know
statistically they seem
extra strong like whoever's running
their twitter has been having a lot of
fun
yeah yeah whoever he or she is running
that has been having a blast and that
would be the point be like
i mean they dropped some fun word
choices in there and i was like this is
amazing i'm loving this
that'd be the point where hey you guys
with those like twisted and uh
uh what is ours blighted rounds like you
guys are kind of breaking our game we're
looking at that just letting you guys
know it's a little strong like
where is that to go right like to go
we've had the fun
and again this was just so bam and i'm
like yeah
wow yeah i was like yeah it's like the
fun police exactly is like tone back the
fun police
the and it's like we'll see where things
land up and stuff like that but when my
build gets hurt that bad i'm like
there's only a few more things i'm going
to be able to do to my build
maybe one different weapon this that or
the other thing and i was just like
i don't know how much more i could do on
mine at least
you know there's some nuanced stuff in a
couple there's tier three mods i'm sure
i could get but
yeah i was like this is this was too
soon i'll just i'll be fine it was just
it was just too soon
so yeah that's all that would just fill
with that and the pve
only component that that's the part
people have to understand
with you know with this when they do
that yeah you're not hurting that many
people this way exactly
that's all we say yep so that's most of
what we got on outriders for you guys
believe me it's like i've have a lot of
fun i don't even know the number of
hours i put into the game at this point
so
but i was like i'm having a blast it's
like i still enjoy and believe me i want
to play the other classes i will because
a lot of other varieties in there but at
this point it just feels like the wrong
time for certain things
and it's like the the the bugs aren't
done yet
yes just just you know pump pump the
brakes that's
that's it i'm willing to get this i
still love the game willing to give give
it a shot i want to see
where else they go with it i want to see
how they continue how they do their
patching and stuff like that
there's going to be fun to modify what
i'm saying just like i said was it
interesting
first week the leaders to say you know i
mean
so on the other side of that we have
destiny
which i haven't actually touched that
much in a little while but what are you
going to do
uh yeah got a press's joint yeah so
first thing on wednesday they did the
dev play through kind of deep dive into
pressage
i actually haven't got a chance to watch
all of it i was kind of part way through
kind of one i know you said that you got
a chance to watch it so what
any cool nuggets you got up there any
yeah
it was it was really good shout out to
dylan they had a lot of people there
eve um the narrative lead they had on as
well
not six people it was really good very
informative just how like
basically structurally how they came up
with it how they went for the haunted
vibe
the choice of using the um the uh what
you call what's the blow creepy crawl
things here oh
screams yeah screams and stuff like that
and how just like
early conceptual how things came
together um you know they wanted to
start the level like when you first go
up to the door and this abandoned ship
how like from a level design standpoint
you know like a normal destination you
just go straight in
and that would be it but they was like
okay we want to let the player know this
is not going to be like that you're
going to have to
kind of basically they wanted to give
the vibe that you're trespassing you're
not supposed to be here
kind of thing so that i thought that was
done well they they talked about
different versions of the skybox
different versions of how
to um enter it and stuff like that they
came up with the uh the mechanic for the
uh when you shoot the walls
and stuff like that they call them the
darkness plants they would call them
darkness plants
but that was fun um it was really cool
then um when you get to like the first
boss encounter
how structurally hot like they had these
cool what was what you would have liked
about it
is they really touched on level design
they really had diagrams showing like
the the the structure of the ship like
they had an outline of the ship and how
each part would go and then um
it would you know accumulating into the
last couple of parts even the boss fight
with the heating up the room and stuff
it was really good it was really good um
there was a couple of guys that were
very excited
during the stream there was one guy
forgot his day he was allowed
yeah oh he was loose bottom left was
luke shout out to you because you're a
passionate guy
but he was just like i got through like
some of the intros and barely getting
started and i can tell
you yeah you know who i'm talking about
bottom left shout out to you we love
what you do
you're a passionate individual sir so he
was in his bag and then um
upper upper right no that was even right
yeah that was eve he was in the field
he was shouting nine hunters guys if you
don't yeah i was like
stop from the show awesome lady yeah
can't wait
i'm gonna watch it i just haven't got
the full thing yet yeah she was in a bag
and then yeah like i said it was just
one of those things and they they talked
about how they applied
some zero hour stuff um
because they said uh because i think
with the you know like
one of those things where you kind of
see where you have to go but there's
that lightning thing
or whatever whatever that that part yeah
yeah they had that and then
then i just appreciated the narrative
guy here too like he really
he touched on some stuff there and how
like you know you're talking
with you know fatal and stuff like that
and that that whole thing with
her and osiris and stuff but yeah
overall it was a classic
solid bungee pressage you know deep dive
what they normally do
and yeah like i said it was it was
pretty strong you get we got i got a
couple nuggets and then last one was the
uh
the trash compactor one i love that one
as soon as you get in there you're like
are they doing it yep they're doing it
like that took like that long when i was
playing it the first time i was like eve
was responsible for that she had a lot
of stay in that
yeah she had a lot of saying and that
whole design she was very happy
that they pretty much kept the the
vision of what it is and then
lower left guy was like yeah then i
decided to just drop screams from the
ground just
because i think dylan's like yo whose
idea was that it's already tension with
the thing
closing on you yeah so that was funny
but yeah it was good it was good it was
a solid solid information you should
definitely check it out
yeah definitely look it up guys you can
check out the full replay it's on their
twitch
archive it'll be sitting there for a
while i'm sure i don't know if they'll
put on youtube or if that'll stay on
twitch they usually
if you see in the 12 though there's a
link straight to it so you can watch it
all so
i'll dig back in to get the rest of that
but if they even have like that's the
old concept art that was up there
they're like
how do we use this for something else i
just like
it's a cool mission and i always like
when they go
when there's so much to that's why i
think some people
underestimate the effort into each of
these
because you see a deep dive you see what
goes in you got the narrative the world
the building
the level design going through and
they're like oh can we have one of these
missions like every season you're like
exactly like the dungeon the secret
mission is
a lot they talked about how much
resources it was just to get the voices
of the dead people that you hear at that
first person counter how much would you
jump
when you jump outside you hear like
whether it's kate or the other pieces
they said how much the it took out of
the audio team just to get that little
part in there and i was like wow i
didn't know that yeah
yeah it's a lot of coordination oh it's
on youtube too okay marvel said it yeah
it's on both so yeah definitely go check
it out wherever you like to watch it but
that's one of those things is like we
want these all the time because they're
amazing
they just take time to make time i was
like and there's not like an
infinite set of teams doing this it's
like you get your senior people on it
you got your
so it's like yeah and it's like it's
very cool because i know eve was part of
um the chatter throne
yes i know that was one of her things
that she was part of too and it's that
world design too
and it's like again it's got a little
more of the the spooky tone but man it's
just like the world designed when you
get in there
and then combined with like the
mechanics and the pay the
puzzle part like maze and all those
things that they put together
there's a lot of team effort you see
going the narrative is given the reason
why you've got the title pieces coming
in the voiceover lines you've got the
art and then ants him down there
visual effects guy in the bottom right
doing his thing as well like
that's a lot of people sitting there
making like one mission and there's a
reason these are
there's a reason the destiny missions
are so special
yes is because they get this level of
effort
so please don't ask for them to be
rushed
i would love one every month i would
never get tired of it but
to get the polish to feel to go through
all the decisions that they get to
they're never going to be perfect but
man they nail these pretty much every
time i don't i can't think of one that i
haven't enjoyed
yeah they've really been killing that's
what i like that they actually celebrate
their own team members and
you know bring that information to us
because again that's gonna have to do
that i mean they're giving us a behind
the curtain
you know thing about it so yeah it was
cool man i always appreciate those
yeah so second thing on the swab was
kilts for kids
always an awesome foundation love to see
the uh the kilt pictures they're awesome
the third guy is hilarious though he's
so eager yeah that one's that one's
pretty damn funny
um but again uh they said help us
achieve our goals 77
000 so they've got the donation links
for that one by donating 10 bucks you
get a chance at the emblem that's down
there
50 bucks gets a chance for a unique
destiny 2 emblem you've got the prizes
uh postcard designed and they go through
all the different tiers and everything
and remember guys just like the all of
their stuff is always 100
to the charity so all of these things
are always extremely good causes
if you're in a financial place where
you're able to definitely
you know look into these because of
course bungie's foundations
and the charities they work with are
always fantastic so always check them
out you get a little bit of you know
little bait gets an emblem a little more
getting you like
copies of like you know you've got
a couple more things that you go through
i don't have to explain them all but
they're there
i mean if you donate a thousand bucks
like if you're sitting in a pretty
financial place
you get all the prizes above plus a one
hour destiny two game session with a
bungee employee and fellow kids for kids
donors like
if you're in a good financial situation
and you love this game and you want to
chat with a destiny dev for a while
they're probably not gonna give you like
spoilers on stuff but you can play with
one of them like
and it's all going to a good cause so
like random stuff like that's always
cool to see
they used to do this tours for like five
grand or something like that you can't
do that right now and obviously there'll
be a new studio at some point but
very cool stuff and now we get into your
your bag
sir yeah we got the uh
we got the iron futures and then we got
uh
some balance stuff man uh we'll start
with iron banner because that's shorter
yeah so hit us up what do we got yeah so
it looks like um we got some
new additions and uh season of redacted
is coming in a few short
weeks so they say sally's got some new
items for us so we got a familiar hand
cannon and sniper will be joining the
fight both to the weapons also making
their debut
our goals for them continue to bring
some year one weapons up to speed with
random roles
but also bring some new rewards into
default when possible
and they said this always depends on a
bit on what resources we have for a
given season that's interesting they
actually said that
yeah and they said uh looking even
further out we're planning
new armor for iron what
these sets won't appear for a few
seasons
but we heard your desire cognito he
boxes
some new digs yes once we have more
information
we'll let you know until then we have
the uh what'd you call a new weapon so
again
looks like some d1 joins i will say i
was very pleased to see
uh a machine gun in the phone no how
long has that been
if ever if ever i can't i don't think
this is d2's
first machine gun or iron banner yeah
yeah
yeah i've never seen that i heard the
hunk the hand count is a 140
not a 120. that's a 140. i was like i'd
have to look up what it is
but yeah i was like i don't know all the
names and everything but i was like it
looked familiar but yeah it's like looks
like shoddy and
machine gun yeah it's like kind of like
the cool art style on there yeah
yep it looks like um the emblems on them
look like
the is an if you look down the emblems
it's like the big barrel of his
inaugural looks like it's slapped on the
side it's almost like
eight of ones helping out salad and make
some uh banana weapons or something
they cook it up they cook it up so yeah
that was dead then uh
yeah hold on
that's literally all we get about iron
banner hey got a couple new weapons and
armors coming soon
there you go are you changing iron
banner ever
no take these methods and shut up
like the token still gonna be there
sounds like it are we gonna get any
intentionality of loot
is there gonna be anything with regards
to umbrals in iron ban
is there anything gonna change for this
man with four bounties and a bunch of
tokens no
wait is the mode ever going to be
anything no
no no they say when we're ready
this always depends so it's like you
said that was an interesting piece where
we get too old and too new that's where
the resource threshold kind of hits
two now again it's two for this and
there's a lot of other stuff going on i
get that
but again what are your thoughts when
you read you know this always depends on
the resources we have for a given season
are you ever i know they're hiring i
know they're growing i know they're
making their massive studio and all this
stuff so they're growing and it takes
time for some of these things but on the
other side
when you're like hey i get two new ones
for season 14. we still don't know how
long season 14 is gonna be gonna be
i'm very curious to either know is it
gonna be three months
three months and then just trials and
iron banner every so often for like a
six month window of fun
going to be interesting i will say this
i thought it was very interesting they
actually said what i've always thought
was it it's the first twab i've
ever seen them say you may get this
depending on what our resources we have
for
i've never seen them say yeah i mean
we've mentioned that over and over and
over and over and beyond what are your
resources what's your bandwidth right
now
is this really the issue yeah it is it
is
it's confirmation it's literally so that
part you know
are we i'm not happy about you know the
limited
stuff we're gonna get no but at the end
of the day i i respect that
finally we got a reason as to what is
going on because that this is what we
all suspected
and they're growing you know we just got
this is going to be the growing pains
until they get to that to that point
so the vibe i've always contended with
now is like
like i always say like season in out
depending on what's going on okay cool
expansion
boom boom pow you know you're gonna get
a lot in that thing and and
what i would say is like every other
season probably is gonna be
whether it be dungeon whether it be now
you know fall
mostly it's coming back next season yeah
so that seems to be the cadence that
we're falling in during this
low resource while they're building up
kind of flow so
not surprised no i mean i'm not but yes
you said it's further we've said it
multiple times we figured that's what it
was you actually see it in
verbiage there to be like hey we are
limited resources
we're not an infinite studio we're
building things we're doing these other
things there's so many different teams
there's only so many artists
there's only so many weapon testers and
creators and programmers and
all those little things take as how many
people it take to make a mission
we saw the the figureheads we saw the
figureheads much less the teams
underneath them doing all these things
and that's one mission so it's like
making stuff isn't cheap and destiny
does you know still try and make things
that have a unique feel and that's not
an easy thing to do
but in turn this is why the weight is on
the expansions and why beyond light
was cool but also felt lacking was that
we didn't get that huge
thing that like holds you over and be
like oh we got a year's worth yeah
you're going to pepper some stuff
through
we didn't get the big years worth it
felt like the only thing that except i'm
sorry
no i was just going to say so that's
where which queen for me the way
like the the way we see these types of
things
for one tells me which queen hopefully
is big but two tells me
if it's like some people might be like
oh it's going to be coming in january
i'm like that thing can be
april for all i care if it's right
that's me on which queen
take their time yeah well i'm curious
about the seasonal length but like
which queen take your time i don't care
yeah i mean listen
what gives me confidence despite i know
people may not like
news like that but what gives me
confidence is when
you say okay you're actually hiring the
game is
actually profitable and then the team
internally
like we saw a couple weeks ago or
whatever it's like punchy
like they like they like ward cry like
yeah like
so something's going on we're internally
there feeling positive
about the future that's always a good
sign and then that virtual summit had
the same feel
which you heard a couple of people say
talk about it
yeah so apparently looking out there on
twitter um
there was virtual summit
something kind of i don't know having to
like describe that basically
before they took like you know members
of the community flew him out to the
studio met all in big giant meeting room
talked to him like narrative people
talked here and they had a whole bunch
of discussions
from like you know people who play the
game of all different places they had
mylan out there from obviously we know
that went well for him which was
fantastic you had people talking about
like pvp guys
pve got like store like all those things
from
and again they tried to get a pretty
good wide range of ideas not just like
top streamer top stream or top like they
got a good mix and
shout out to the first one i thought it
went from was d flawless
uh guys the flawless is out there well
it's in there in the little zoom in the
little zoom in the zoom you know what i
mean
but like virtually one of those where
we'll see they're their thing the
question is
when they do these is when they're at a
weird point
of course so
what i wanted to ask you is like thing
like things aren't bad this season
people drink but trials is like just
getting ripped on
week after week now again it's got some
some things but obviously it needs fix
like pvp is not
like do you think it was a pvp based
summit more
do you think where do you think it was
what do you think it was kind of if they
got d flawless
a lot of his stuff is pvp you know and
joking and stuff like that he's
oh my god oh yeah if you guys don't
follow him god
you're killing me yeah i gotta we gotta
reach out to the floor he's he's
oh i did it i'm working on it oh well by
me you know what i said so yeah
he he's alive so look you know it's been
the butt of every joke we know what the
deal is
you know and it's got to be addressed so
what are what are they doing and then
the communities you know feedback on
that
and then my guess the other part would
probably be the seasonal content
structure a little bit too
maybe you know leveling
that's i guess that would be the other
side is because you've got i mean
coo jay he better have been invited he's
won
for sure because he's been like trying
to remake their game for him he's one of
those i wonder because
making this game is not easy they've got
a whole lot of stuff going on he's like
well you could do this this this this
this
whether you're a developer not like i
don't know if you're a game dev or not
but it's still one of those it's like if
he goes through like eight videos hey
let me tell you how to rebuild their
game
i'm really curious how that's received i
mean constructive criticism he does it
in a nice way
of course of course but it is always one
of those i wonder that's like
how was some of that taking be like oh
you just need to do this this and this
and like i wonder if bungie's like and
here's the white notepad of pages why we
can't like okay
exactly and and that and that would be a
fair discussion to like
bring somebody in for that virtual and
have but it's still like that's some of
those i
really wonder it's like okay here's this
and they're sitting there like
believe me yeah it's like they're sure
but also there's
you know this slew of other things that
say we can't do this for this this that
that the other
because of whatever limitations old
consoles engine
timing resources so many different
things could go into why they can't
right yeah i mean usually like i said
the summits to me are always
whatever the weaknesses are whatever
whatever the flaws are whatever the
community is the most upset about pvp
has to be like i said
at the top of that list you know like i
see people talking about all
knowing that i saw my perk combination
stuff like that you know
there's still things and again the level
i think we're at that point now
with the power level grind that that
fatigue with it
oh and and what they're going to do with
that that's got to be another point of
contention
that they've got to figure out so and
then i'm
i'm very curious if uh
unset setting came back up and that kind
of stuff as
far as it had to be like hey somebody's
like so you guys want to explain why
that all happened or that like
yeah i want to be the i want to hear the
person who broached that subject and be
like
so sunsetting not sunsetting wipe some
of the old stuff out
can you explain why like i don't know if
they told him or not but i would be very
curious to like
because again it was that whole like it
lasted three months
so weird so weird yeah i
i that is dead one day one day we gotta
get one of us gotta get you gotta get
the call
you gotta get the call man like i would
love to be in one of those rooms
in these summits man these summit could
you imagine like
classic ones was what right after
cursive osiris that was a classic one
you know i would love to be in there to
see what they got cooking for these
future
remember those guys get to get to see
future seasons i believe right a little
i mean they've seen
yeah they've seen previews of stuff
that's probably where the big bungee
cheers coming from
um all that stuff so it's like they
probably get a tease of what's coming
they're probably like here's this
question well this is being solved
here with this like they might have
those types of back and forth
and i was like and i would love to just
pick the brains on
even if i have a question as to hey i
don't think this is the right thing
why is this this way this is my opinion
in my head is one sample size of one not
four million
right what does this say is you're like
80 casual based say this
is your hardcore people you guys like we
just had to stop listening to them
because
most of like we had seen drop-offs here
this like
that's the type of stuff i would love to
just pick their brain ever
oh yeah and i was like i was like and of
course like and you know you'd sign an
india of your life away on that type of
stuff but it's like those are the
questions when you're like
i would just love to know some of these
things even just so i have that
knowledge in the back of my head to be
like
i get it i may not agree with it but i
get it like those things get their minds
yeah
yeah it's about learning their mindset
why they
do the things they do what's the thought
process because there is some things to
where again we are not privy to the data
yeah so there's some things that we like
yo that's the dumbest what the hell is
this stupid
and then we like oh okay no one's using
it or no ones whatever or
hey this really helps casuals and look
at these numbers that support that we
know the very number
number number driven so um yeah like ah
man
one day budget one day man you gotta
gotta get the cat fire in there man got
it
we gotta see what's going on behind the
curtain got lifted up
yeah someday some day sometimes but as
for the other piece
it was literally a day of like changes
balancing nerfs on two different games i
was like
all right we're just gonna do it all in
one day and just get it out of the way
get it going oh come on sandbox is you
man you want
i'll do it i'll do it but i was like
sandboxes
i like to give these to you because
you're like you don't get your sandbox
wagon dude
this is all me right here so yeah the
never ending search for balance
perfect for season of redacted we got to
get that day we have a few changes that
will be coming to the destiny sandbox
this week
we'll be focusing on things that are hot
weapons
and archetypes that need to be tuned in
order to create breathing room for
other aspects of the destiny sandbox to
shine remember what i said
oh this is a lot of the reasons for
their nerf so other things can go up so
please people stop saying they don't do
that anyway
we're also planning quite a few buffs to
underuse perks
linear fusion rifles put your hands
together guys put your hands together
dust them off y'all and more the current
plan is to cover perks and web buffs in
an upcoming 12
towards the end of april once they're
solidified but we wanted to get this
information out
earlier than normal to keep you from
yeah earlier though when that means
outriders is here and we need to give
you something that's what that
continues i know how budget they
this is where they start to try to cook
up a little bit anyway without further
ado
man chris proctor is once again here to
lead out to lay out the goals
when these upcoming changes give you the
nitty gritty weapon
archetypes aggressive 120 rpm hand
cannons are
those popular right now are those
i think i think they're popular yeah
yeah those don't remember though
um we've received enough feedback that
we want to rein them
in a bit without completely taking away
their range benefits
the first bullet was these weapons will
now have damage
and aim assist fall off distance reduced
between two and four meters
based on the range that got no problem
with that
this roughly half the range buff they
received in beyond light
then we got vortex frame swords with
fallen guillotine now viable forever
we need to adjust it a little as its
damage output is flat out higher than
all other legendary swords with this
change were allowed to keep its high
damage output
but are reducing its full reserve damage
output by reducing the number of heavy
attacks you will be able to perform
so that heavy attack ammo was going to
the cost is going to be increased
from 4 to six interesting curriculums
about what you thought about that
ship damage
certain weapons swords and bastion
shields by
bypass shields by varying amounts which
has caused numerous issues
with stasis encased enemies encountered
that's interesting
encountering mechanics encounter
mechanics and other content
we have removed ship damage from swords
i don't actually know what this is like
what this is related to though i really
don't i mean i know i understand the
concept of ship damage
but also it's like a bypass by my
understanding it's almost like a
bypass almost like normal it's like does
anybody in chat know like what this is
specifically related to or
they say encounter mechanics stasis
encased enemies
i don't know if it's pvp pve like the
chip damage
this seems very pve because by
certain weapons like the swords that
bypass shields by
various so basically it's a shield
ignorer yeah
on a lot of these enemies so this is
definitely feeling very
pve-ish yeah but i feel like swords
definitely been a thing if you are going
to use them on like
i've been able to probably break through
shields even with the wrong matchmaking
the wrong match yeah yeah
okay that might be it because i've done
that in lost sectors with
say one thing and there's one guy with
one other shield time i'm like well i've
got a sword it's powerful enough i can
still bust through that
and then keep going so it's like that's
prep makes more sense okay so now
they've removed it
completely it seems right we have a
remote chip damage from swords and
bastion yep
that that's a big deal all right so
perks here we go
quick draw this perk hold on i just want
to go back up to the
vortex frame sword thing you were
talking about that's good let's get the
archetypes down
uh 120s i mean i'm not a pvp expert by
any means but in listening to enough of
firing range and stuff like that
obviously those guys love your steady
hands your igneous hammer is like
igneous hammer is god because it can run
it's 120 and it's also got a range of
massive range and it can almost have the
most so you're going to bring them down
some they're still probably going to be
potent i would imagine they're probably
just trying to give a little life to the
others
a little risk versus award uh they're
still probably going to be strong i'll
be curious to hear what they say
the one you mentioned about the frame
swords swords always have a risk reward
especially in pve because you're gonna
get stepped on right
stepped on kicked like or smashed in the
face with a shield one way or the other
um so
i don't know i mean i know that one
sword is specifically higher
but i don't think anybody's been saying
falling guilty and still absolutely
amazing it destroys everything that's
like
and i know they talked about limits down
below i know they're talking so it's
just getting there too
before yeah yeah so it's like okay so
then you're gonna bring up linear fusion
rifles it's like
all right we're gonna give linear fusion
rifles 11.6 percent and i'm just going
to be like okay
we don't know that no we don't you
authority and fake stats
no i know it won't be the auto rifle of
0.02
i know it's not going to be that it is
weird though it's like it is
and this is again this is like a
frustration as a player to be like hey
you give me a linear fusion rifle but
they still suck
okay one this makes me wonder
you know certain things about what
weapons are coming next season
what the encounters are going to be like
for sure are people using swords to
smoke atheon
right oh i forgot about that so it's
like there are certain encounters where
this stuff may be powerful but on the
other side
rockets were the example i would use for
so long the everyone was like rockets
are weak rockets are weak rockets are
weak and it's not like hey here's ten
percent
here's ten percent here's ten percent
they're week week week week week week
eighteen months later here's thirty
percent
right linear fusions have been sitting
here this time now for a while they've
been weak they've been weak they've been
weak they've been waiting
terrible so the question for me from
when we say that is there
within a season we can only test this
archetype to in-depth to see about the
numbers to go into and if they say yes
then i'm like
then i get it that might be i don't know
again i don't know the testing process
but i got to feel like
why is it is it the intention of the
shifting the meta
is that like their goal but it's like
why when linear fusion raffles
everybody's like
error does this video hey linear
fusion's good yep nope still not good
even with frenzy nope still not good
and then finally here you go here's this
chunk is this the
is this the seasonal shift of the meta
thing that they want to do or is it like
i want it
so what do you think i i think i don't i
think what it is
is it's what you said at the beginning
but what happens with them is this
they have penalized i think you know
what i learned it
with scouts they outright
said scouts are never going to get
anything else besides this aim assistant
because what i've learned from them is
besides
us being in the bubble and melting stuff
they don't like us
at a distance melting stuff okay so then
what's wrong with the sword
i'm literally underneath his foot i
agree with you i
i i'm like damn we just swords just felt
the wrath
last last patch notes you know i said
and we're going to see more with paul
lament more i'm like damn
but the thing is i'll be honest
i thought linear fusions were you know
i'm team sleeper you know
i thought linear fusions would never get
a buff because i thought they were going
to apply that same mentality
that they do with scouts because let's
be honest linear fusion to stay at the
back of the map
and pop shot not that they were well
sleeper at his prime was doing the most
but legendary linears they didn't really
have
that much of a long run but the reality
is they just don't like
the sniper guy the linear fusion guy
back of the map
doing all this dps i don't agree with it
okay i was gonna say it's like that's
one of those telling me how to play half
of your game
right you're gonna have weapon types of
sniper scouts linear fusions that are
range from distance
but you're gonna make them well it's a
risk curse award like you can't make it
like
yeah i have less risk so i have like
negative 20 rewards versus the guy who's
closer with a hand cannon
or a sword and then swords are going to
get shot down too it's like
there are different play styles it's
about trying to find the balance and
it's just like
they really as you said they really do
not like the range
but like you can also see it the way
they've done boss encounters yes
everything is like an arena stuff moves
you can't
most and like sepex is like an old style
you can see it
you can still hide in the back you can
pluck away shield brothers and dark uh
taken king was when they started
circular like boss or
like circular arenas specifically those
were almost all that way
you have no place to hide right there's
not much room if you pull out a sniper
you can't see outside of your periphery
so then they really felt like
okay we're going to make the encounters
that make the risk of like looking down
a sniper rifle getting a couple maybe
you get a couple big shots
right i felt like they were okay there
so it's always it's
again these are questions where i'd love
to know the why
that they can't say publicly they don't
want massive boss dps from a distance
that's why i see you new red but bulls
ain't killing bosses like that
they are coming for linear fusion
snipers
you know what i'm saying all that
straight line super accurate
you know and scott or scouts not too
much but even though scouts caught the
rap anyway but
like they just don't like it they they
they've
literally outright snitched they said
they don't like it he doesn't say
so in this case to me this is them
throwing the bone actually going to do
something now here's the funny part
let's not get too excited because we
heard this from scouts
and they were like yeah your aim assist
is going to go to the roof baby
so i'm not going to get crazy that they
going to do something
no monstrous with linears they might
give us an
amos's value back that they nerfed
because of the gambit remember gambit
linears were in his prime everything
pre-gambit
was linear was doing good as soon as
gearbest came out there's like nope
that whole class got nerfed because of a
mode i'm gonna die on that sort
you know so now it's gonna be
interesting to see what they do but i
agree with you i feel the swords are
unfair
i feel that it's risk reward if i got to
do a a
a loss sector like you like you usually
do solo
and i gotta run up on there well that is
tremendous risk i'm putting myself
then you got every boss doing a stop
mechanic
knocking me all the way to you know
what's this like
so many ways that you can't use the
things that they give you sometimes yeah
i was like and this is what this is why
the happiness of outriders was like you
hate to see the fun go
cause it has been fun to just break it
in pvp because i mean gmd said it really
well i summed it up swords were never
used
they're not a big thing right now and
now they'll never be they'll be used
less heavy machine guns basically adds
only they nerf the damage on those
snipers are hit and miss izanagi's
whisper depends on the encounter
nerfs and those things linear fusions
not amazing unless you give it a big
bump
so essentially the new metabo will be
anarchy and divinity so then they fall
back into
couple exotics everybody like you want
to like mix up the game
right anarchy everybody still uses that
one exotic and that's still apparently
they're fine with it
which is really weird like the divinity
and the anarchy is still
everywhere you're telling me you're not
going to put divinity
and something i don't know what the
choice is going to be
maybe a couple i mean atheon's going to
get melted divinity
is an augie and they're going to be
damaged
they're going to put that damage check
yeah you're going to have a you're going
to i mean maybe
but it was like you're going to have a
divinity sitting on
atheon and his big like waistband
bubbles going to be going on and people
are just going to be
maybe they're sitting with their you
know shotguns again little slug shotguns
with extra range in a well or so
those types of things are what we're
going to fall back to so it's like it's
i will be curious to see the changes but
it's like it does get to a point where
you see anarchy
divinity is just that like that's what
it is it's like that's the way to play
we know how this goes we've been we've
seen this from
seven years now yeah but i'm going to
give you up to give you the playbook
just case you forgot
this is what's going to happen they're
going to nerf these joints that we talk
about right
and all right cool we're going to be
upset we're going to cry
then the content going to come out
they're going to introduce
a couple of exotics or weapons with new
perks in these other archetypes that are
gonna be amazing
and we're gonna go crazy and we're gonna
say oh my god this is it
and we're gonna have that for a strong
season and a half
and then that gonna get so basically
they come in
hot overpowered with the new stuff like
with frenzy we're going to
talk about debut when lament debuted
remember
oh my gosh swords have been hit once and
it's getting hit again
and again this this what they do i think
it's data driven i think it's to the
point where it's like high engagement
and lower it down bro it's it's
literally
get them excited about this shiny new
toy let them fall in love
then we take it away here's the next new
toys we want you to play with
it's this it's cyclical bro it's the
same thing every season no that's
that's why we're liking outriders right
now because it's this weird
feeling of feeling good about
going ham on everything and literally
everything
yeah right and that's why we you know we
get into that thing but even when stasis
debuted it was just
oh my god you're gonna say now they
reeling back
you know what i'm saying that's the
thing so again at the end of the day
i know that i know the vibe you know
what i'm saying i understand what's
going on
my whole thing is content the quality of
the content
and then obviously because of what's
happening now we got this weird gap
because we were doing good
with story story story story okay cool
yes
now we got this weird gap now we're like
okay what now
you don't say it is oh banana again you
know ready for guardian games
no so uh i mean you can throw that
straight
but i don't know that is literally from
now i think the season literally ends in
a month
right so not this coming tuesday the
next tuesday is guardian games
right the only links i've really heard
is you actually have to pick a class
which isn't bad i'll give them that
right
um but other than that it's like is that
exciting for me not really i think it
might be
rumors like a catalyst for heir apparent
we'll be curious what it does
it's all hopefully it's not too crazy of
a grind for it but overall it's like
yeah it's
i will say though in credit though they
didn't have the season like all the way
to the end
they do give you a break i would rather
have a front loaded season
and then those who want to keep playing
yeah yeah other people you can break a
break to play some other stuff i agree
i enjoyed the front load the gap feels
weird right now outriders is the perfect
fix
exactly so it's like we'll just that's
right i'd rather at least have that but
it feels a little weird but i'm still
more okay with it the last point before
we get into the next joint is that
i i completely agree i like the front
loaded season you know what i'm saying
and then for the people who can't catch
up the casuals
they're still rocking or whatever
whatever we're good we're rocked out
but here's the thing and we're gonna get
i know we're getting into this
that's the outright thing i gotta
mention it see the differences
is when that raid hit
or what that dungeon hit that's what
outriders don't have
oh no see that's the difference when
that hit
and you got in-game content and you got
the secret mission you got
that's when it gets that's when you see
everybody
all the worries go out the window when
we doing that
in-game stuff and that's all i want not
to make this a comparison competitive
thing
i just worry without right is that once
we do expedition
10 and whatever it is what is left
because at the end of the day the reason
why destiny survives
is end game in these these cool type of
missions like pressage
and zero hour and this you know
shattered thrones and all
that's what keeps us going it's unique
and it's so many so many things
i just want them to do that what's up no
and i was going to say that's exactly
what outright or that's what exactly
what out writers know they're not
they intentionally said like what you
buy is what you get this you know you
have your expeditions the grind for the
end game it's like paragon levels
and i don't know what the dungeons are
called for diablo
it's that type of thing to try and go
for the ultramin max for those who
want to but it is not like the secrets
because that's
so many people come from destiny
expecting anything like that and it's
like
it's not nothing not that right it is
not and that's the difference now
what i do hope for at some point is when
they drop say
outriders poland expansion
yes that's right that's the piece that
people are going to be like
as long as they leave you feeling good
about it right that's the key that's
what i want
that is when those expansions will just
hit bam all out there's expansion
we got more challenge tiers we've got
new world tiers we've got new mods
there's
nothing you can go about because that's
the type of thing
that's what that's that cl that's that
play style that's that game
that that's what i need and that that
stuff and that's gonna be a while
that's because they didn't plan for it
because we go my thing is
again and in fact they're not even
playing for it it's my thing is once we
we get that we get our bills and we do
what we got to do
right you know i want something to come
back even if it's a couple months down
the road
i understand it's not gonna be that fast
damn not even a couple of months now
three four so what you think what's your
guesstimate on the next
outriders whatever you had to guess
a year and a half maybe two wow
i mean if they're gonna do so i mean
picture diablo
like what uh something chaos or lords of
destruction those aren't fast
those are never months later they're
year like a year later
you don't think they'll do like a dlc
structure maybe nope nope
nope nothing no zero that's why i'm
trying to break everybody's mentality of
this it's not
happening i'm serious
because so many people i say is this
comment you've said it multiple times on
the podcast because of what destiny has
ingrained in your head
it is not that i get it i just will keep
playing
i got it i didn't that's i get it and
that might be again
you got to watch how much fun you steal
from like the 60-hour person who's put
that 60 hours in a week no question for
somebody who wants to spread that 60
hours over like
months because they're still going to be
able to go through that and have fun if
they leave and have fun and be like
all right i got to the end my build's
pretty fantastic there's some other
stuff pulling me away cool new expansion
sweet i'm right back
do you want them to leave that way no
that's fine but my question
hasn't borderline i'm looking at like
borderlands like not even
they never said they're doing that no
they they had dlc content they did
they did but they had it planned up
front
they were like here's these things that
are going to be coming out
people can fly said nope so they say
straight up no wig
wow that is there is nothing planned
announced period and that's different
from borderlands and diablo because
borderlands had that diablo didn't
borderlands did borderlands is like kind
of a
is like tried to halfway live service
like you know borderlands and division
they have their seasonal things that
kind of
okay fine sure borderlands i hear my
brother said the story
the stories each time are actually
pretty fun in it because they're just
crazy i thought we would get story
content like hey this is what's going on
with the altered
you know new you know not like a
seasonal moment of course
and that's that's the thing is like you
would see okay
from here now we've built another story
like another like campaign piece more
like that's what they did in diablo it's
like
right i'm gonna look it up now because
honestly i'm curious the difference
between the two diablo
but to me it's it's it's almo i
understand
they're two different type of game
that's not what i'm trying to compare to
what i'm trying to compare is the game
that it is
in that genre i've seen other games say
okay
you know later on or whatever it is if
it's later in the fall
or the top of 2022 we're gonna have you
know
what you call an expansion and then this
is you know maybe a
not another class but you know more
story beat you know
a little more weapons or whatever okay
take diablo three now granted blizzard
takes a while to do things i get that
but two years till reprove souls came
out
two years that's literally like and
again reaper of souls and diablo loot
2.0 is the thing in that game as well
two years that's why i say it's like
they are
so because their whole goal was getting
out they
that's literally one of the things you
buy the complete package everything
you're gonna get
in this thing we have no plan for
anything else they've said
if the game is received well if it does
well which i'm pretty sure it's
doing it it's received well right then
they can work on other stuff but they
had to make sure this thing that got out
there
they nailed the marketing communication
as long as they don't screw up the like
balancing and stuff
they've nailed so many things there will
be something but it's not what i'm
saying it's got to be this is a money
maker
but it's not going to be that fast no
i'm not saying it's got to be fat
where are you getting that got to be
fast literally like months later
no months later i'm asking a question
but i'm not saying it has to be that i'm
not implying that they're going to be
pumping stuff up into seasonal content
like destiny
i'm not going there i'm just saying in a
year we can't get a a a new dlc
maybe like maybe a year year and a half
that's why i said you're gonna have to
give them time though it's like
the expansion is going to be as long as
something's coming that's all i'm saying
there probably is with the success of
the relationship oh we're done that's it
you you got it no but you literally said
like two minutes ago you're like we're
not getting anything like months from
now no you just said that a minute ago
though asking you because you're the
ambassador
i don't know any more than you guys
besides all the stuff i've watched i'm
not saying it's definitely
but i'm just asking a question but yeah
so my understanding is
they wanted the complete package that
you buy it you got it all done
okay they didn't they're like we have
nothing planned for the future until we
see how things go
they just want to make sure what they
release works once they get things
balanced networking patching all that
stuff is good whatever they figure out
then depending on the success which it
seems to have gone very well
i expect something like a lords of
destruction but the timing of it is what
i'm saying
to make it worth your while if you're
gonna do a paid expansion which it
probably would be
they're probably gonna do one more class
i would guess
to make that worthwhile to jump in gonna
have a crap ton of new mods to come in
maybe they do another tier four i don't
like whatever level they go to
is gonna be that it's gonna be a bigger
piece and that's gonna take them
especially for their team size and
whatever they do
that's that 18 months two years year to
two year mark
that it's going to be that far that's my
guess with everything i know because i
don't know much more than
if you read between the lines in there
like press coverage right
and my guess is all i'm saying is
because of the success
of the how well it's received right how
good it's doing
they're at that point where it's it's in
it it's insatiated
they've got cachet so now they know okay
people love it
we're you know invested in it you know
now we got to go ahead
to eventually start planning out
whatever extra content that's what i'm
saying
yeah i was like and unfortunately that's
just like they're
they don't have a calendar because they
don't want to set any expectations i
think that's the biggest thing
they've seen these people be like hey
here's this well we had to push like
well look at division two
they had a plan in a calendar anthem
had a plan in a calendar those calendars
you may as well just throw them in the
trash
so that's why i think their fear of
setting any expectation of
when things are going to come they did
not want to do that to give themselves
the freedom to be like hey this thing's
out we're working on this and then they
can just be quiet work on it and be like
bam
hey in six months in the fall we're
gonna come out um
i'll tell you as well yeah he's going
[Laughter]
blink
wow
i gotta get them that's why i'm asking
these questions my man no
no no
he had the official showcase coverage
full build before the game is even
out um got it got to be bigger but
and that's the thing is like you say
like cyberpunk likes
gmd said it as well anything that had a
planned calendar
outside of destiny's probably one of the
few and they've had a little delays but
overall they've managed theirs they're
one of the few that have been like
pretty close but most often
it's just like anthem cyberpunk division
two
anything that tried to maintain anything
live tends to have failed
yeah yeah they want to be like zero
expectations you buy this here's
outrighters period
if anything else happens it's literally
a bonus
later that they will announce and i have
no idea expectation
or timing of what that will be period
stop trying to read like blinking sos
with my eyeball if you guys aren't
watching the video and you aren't in
chat you're missing out so if you watch
this on audio please
jump into uh chat
[Laughter]
but that's like that's why i've been
like i think i've said it before because
anytime i hear somebody
thinking anything is coming i want to
nip it in the butt because i don't want
that expectation out there
because corporate got you good right now
you're you're so media trained bro i
love you yo they did a good job with you
brother i i'm really impressed man
you're on the right track bro
i gotta it's been a long since we had
one-on-one i gotta mess with you
i gotta mess with you
but that's but i was like but i honestly
like that
though is good because like they've said
this is what you get right now there's
not like uh like enjoy what's here have
fun
and that they want to and again it's
like that's why i worry for them
how people leave your game because
that's the diablo quote and if you want
to listen to anybody
like if they leave your game make them
leave happy like glad couldn't get 100
hours in the first two weeks because he
doesn't sleep
but if he had a blast playing it and
people like hey jill of hours dude it
was a blast go get it it's totally fun
if that's his just like if that's how he
feels about it sold they'll continue to
sell people will jump on game pass oh
yeah that's on there cool i'll go jump
on that oh it's leaving game pass well
i'm still not done buy it like
that's how you want people to end with
that game yeah however long they play it
so that's why
that's why the nerf hurt me more is
because
of this is all it is for now don't mess
it up
and it felt so good so that's where i
know i'm passionate about that for a
piece but it's just one of those where
i'm like for me
it's one of those things where it's just
i'm a little worried so
back to the sandbox stuff sorry about
that tangent i don't even know this was
good we had to get it out we had to get
it out that was good that was good
no i got it i got to time stamp the
tangent though and see if i can get it
in there that was good that was good
without it it was really good man i
really appreciate it
we love what they're doing we just want
everything with that joint to succeed
so well yeah perks man i think we were
jumping into that and that quick draw
so the perk is intended to provide
faster swap speed but it also
passively buffs handling by plus 100
which i didn't know
this completely negates the downside of
using low handling weapons such as
aggressive shotguns snipers and hand
cannons
which isn't something we want to
encourage those weapons should have
downsides and working around those
completely via a perk
isn't healthy we don't think allowing a
fast swap to the shotgun sub family
with the highest one-hit kill range is a
great either
so the handling bonus is now removed
one second after switching to this
weapon or upon aiming down sights
replaced quick draw with surplus on new
and existing drops of fel winter's lie
and astral horizon i have a question
replaced quick draw with surplus on new
and existing exit meaning that
your our farewell fell winters in the
stash will wake up with a new boy
and astral now the one astral yeah
see and here's the issue on the other
side
bungie could never win because this is a
live service game they're like well
we undid setting these other things we
were going to have changed
now we've got to do something different
it's different now the issue
you see and i just you see one person
say this and i'm just like
yup this sucks they're adept astral
if they got one with quickdraw now
is not their gun and they spent the time
to go flawlessly to a lighthouse to get
this weapon
and now it's been and now that's been
specifically like something you were
like holy
nerfed that's one of those that feels
real
bad like feels bad man bad level
big and fell winters now fell winter as
we know has been god tier for way way
too long
but again that's one of those that's
tough because this is something now phil
winters is like most people can get from
a quest
the adept astral if it's got quick draw
on it that hurts
for somebody that's their play style so
i know there's a lot of pvp
people who will be like well now you
gotta learn another play and that's
where bungie
has to make some of those hard calls
right i don't play shotguns that much
this doesn't
this my except astral yeah this is god's
here right here
this is the this is the form you know i
mean and
exactly what you say because now they're
in a tough spot and this is what
happened
when you're on sunset you know what i'm
saying because now
we're in this bag right and now people
who have earned stuff
are going to feel away that definitely
we'll get into it but um
frenzy this perk has extremely high
uptown in pve
to the point where it's clearly a better
choice than most other damaged perks
we we like the high uptown and want to
preserve that but want it to award
less damage than harder to activate
damage perks
reduce bowman's damage from plus twenty
percent to plus fifteen percent
see that's that's not bad that doesn't
have a nerf i wish they didn't outriders
starts yes yes start small yeah
increment that's what i like that they
do reservoir bursts this is a special
one for me
now increases magazines loaded question
it's my favorite i was like somebody's
like
upcoming content requires revisiting the
power level and damage perk that can be
activated simply like
i'm like okay hold on though i keep
seeing loaded question because that's
like the pinnacle fusion rifle your
first
shot and especially the fast reload but
the first shot would cause the big
explosion of ads it was fun for clearing
cool if they reissue a pinnacle i'm
going to punch somebody
no no no this is what you ain't even
missing it bro this is it going to be a
perk for somebody
the perks coming back perks coming back
that's what
hey see i'm cool with this because my
thing was
i was so anti-pinnacle retirement
but then when we saw the messenger and i
saw desperado come back
bro i want to give a standing ovation
okay this is what i'm i'm good with this
this is a good thing because even though
you're not bringing pinnacles you're
gonna bring some of those perks back and
now we could have someone at a weapon
pool
this is good reservoir burst literally
makes
fusions viable in pve that
that was one of loaded questions was one
of my babies this is a good thing this
is a good thing y'all
trust me so anyway let's get that let's
get to the bad now
exotics the limit this
weapon is a clear outlier no
for sword damage so for the health of
heavy weapon
diversity we're pulling it back a bit
reduced damage of
revved heavy attack by approximately 16
note that the lament retains standard
anti-barrier despite removing
chip damage hmm thoughts
uh reduced damage of rev by 16
it already got hit before and then the
chip damage is still gonna be
anti-barrier it's fine
i'm sure it's still going to be decent
but again it's like this thing i think
has been hit twice now
you got the swords coming down the
spinny swords like they
they made swords they were fun and it's
kind of what you said you had your fun
fun's gone for a while if they do want
to bring it back maybe be like
swords like let's have this discussion
in
june of 2022 swords have not been used
in a while so what we wanted to do is
buff them up
and increase their usage in the heavy
loot pool we've also reduced the amount
of the stomp knockback
and other things it sounded like a d
flawless tick-tock
but like that's exactly what that's
going to be like past
like that seriously d flawless like if
you listen but like we'll get you on
that's your pastor's future talking to
each other hey swords are really strong
right now we're going to knock them down
hey swords that haven't been used in a
while we're going to bring them right
back up it's like
did what happened in the meantime yeah
that's
i mean that's what like i can just
picture it's like we're gonna this is
the cycle
this is the roller coaster of destiny as
you said the problem
when you have to a pve and a pvp
component
yep that's what it is because when you
do something on one it affects the other
and then you got this back and forth
with the pve that's the problem
anyway um bastion since we're removing
chip damage
bastion gets something else instead
we've noticed increased feedback on
bastion and higher than normal usage in
pvp
so we are making a small change here and
will revisit bastion later
intrinsically staggers unstoppable
champions
increase spread angle by thirteen
percent and mercury lisa said
yeah that's that's that's mercury i
literally was watching fallout as he was
reading through some of the patch notes
because i was looking at the same time i
was like oh
and then i saw that thing i was like i
wonder if he's here yet because i was
curious
about the pvp thing and then he got too
basty and he's like oh somebody called
mark kelly somebody tweet mark kelly's
right now
the spread angle like i gotta hear i
gotta hit my boy's scream one home
scream is a bastion
guy there's a few of them but it's
powerful yeah and that spread now at
range
it's gonna be a little it's gonna be
harder to hit that yeah those shots
it's gonna be hard to hit that [ __ ] in
pv again in pve
it's gonna be fantastic it's gonna have
an
unstoppable champion intrinsic
but in pvp again that's the thing
that that that's the issue so anyway
what all about this channel we'll
continue to watch how they play out once
in a while
we'll look to make further adjustments
based on the observations and player
feedback
so yeah and we'll talk to you guys in
about three to six months
for the next balance patch stop it
[Laughter]
i mean it does feel little things can be
tweaked
but their big cadence still seems like
seasonally yeah it's seasonal it's
season
it's it's always seasonal so that's
that's the uh the latest but yeah i mean
for me
sucks about lament you know lament that
that that hurts we'll see how it
plays out yeah it's still anti-barrier
but you know
that with the chip damage i don't know
how it it's gonna play out
that i gotta see and then um i do like
bastion
with the uh the the unstoppable i don't
know how the chip damage gonna play on
pve but i do like that
i like having unstoppable intrinsic
stuff sometimes exotics um
like what's the other one leviathan's
breath yeah frenzy
i don't mind that's not nothing i mean
20 to 15 whatever
reservoirs is huge that is that is such
an
ad clear that is suc and actually
underrated dps when you have the full
um what you call it it really could do
some damage to bosses
quick draw you know where i'm at with it
is kind of like look
it's not gonna feel good for anybody who
who god rolled that
that that's not gonna feel good i'm not
going to sit there and just yeah
um you know poo poo that what i will say
is
they they probably figured out a way to
rein in
um fell winters and no style
you know what i mean now the question is
whenever they this is how they operate
they always do
these type of nerves again to set up
supposed fun that's going to be coming
with this new
meta and this new sandbox or these
weapons that they introduce so we got to
see we got to see i'm half and half some
things i like some things i didn't like
but overall you know we we shall see oh
that was
bird bro he said you don't think they
don't buff other things to bring up
because they don't want us smoking
bosses i just feel they tend to nerf
more than buff for some reason i would
agree with that yeah
yeah they might introduce something a
little strong as you said but a lot of
things i feel like
have been i haven't felt a whole lot of
things like rockets
were so bad for so long when we finally
do see a buff it's like it's so long
overdue it's like thanks but it's like
too little too late type don't be don't
be messy be messy when you get a buff
i'm just saying but that's like it is a
weird it is a weird about it feels
more frequent that things are still
being like slowly
whittled down and again it's always the
wonder of
do they bosses still feel chunky and
have damaged and stuff like that so the
sponginess doesn't go away it's not like
bosses have a little bit of health and
they're more mechanic-based
we don't want you to do too much damage
to do this thing it's still
i don't know it's i don't know they
don't have an easy win ever
i get that so they're trying to do the
best that they can and they're focused
on certain archetypes
some of them are just like weird when
it's like the entire community's like
hey rockets rockets rockets rockets
rocket rockets rockets
and then we do finally see it we're like
yeah thanks
i mean it's always you know i guess
people feel to your point
the buffs are like a season too late so
to speak
or more yeah or more times you know
shout out to khakis he'd been on team
linear fusion rifles so he was popping
bottles when he saw
lydian fusion supposed to get something
out yeah shout out to he said can we
kinetic autos wow yeah i didn't think
about that
some impact damage would be nice for
trams yeah shot to get a track graviton
metal was serious
that was a fun one that was serious man
that
because that was the that was the meta
of lance and vigilance wing those were
the two
that ray and supreme we got to see
they're definitely playing in a new meta
we we got to see what's going on they
always give us the
the bad news first and then the season
comes out and then they tell you like
the whole
get all the nerfs out of the way here's
the new season hype trailer yeah
[Laughter]
everybody's like oh yeah and then they
settle in six like eight weeks later oh
yeah
damn yep yep that's how it goes but
that's that's what i got man i was
surprised to see this a little earlier
i know i came up
certain other game was getting fractured
i mean if you're going to do it i
wouldn't drop bad news on that day they
didn't they'd
be like hey here's a tease image if they
want to build hype
give like the artifact image for the
next season that's how you play against
it like
yeah that's that's how you tease and be
like hey we didn't want to do too much
but here's like
here's like a quarter of the picture of
an artifact just like start
building that baby you know they're
stupidly good at marketing like
insanely good at it so it's like if they
really wanted to play the if that was
their goal
they had other ways they could do it i'm
gonna tell you how this when that
dude sees a trailer hit
that's the other piece of why outriders
hit at the perfect time
oh perfect like literally nothing is
going on in gaming right now it's not a
damn thing and you're just like
everybody's going to play this yep it
came at the perfect time and good
shout out to them man i said i'm
enjoying myself i have a great hotel i'm
going to try that pyro
just as my lower level character when
i'm running with other people yeah no i
mean pyro like the and that's again
that's the other thing i would say about
outriders is until you get towards like
a full skill tree get a lot of mods
synergizing with your build
find a couple weapons that even like for
a pyromancer you can get like weapons
that cause ash and then you can have ash
do certain things and all this starts
playing together
it takes a little while to get there
so if you have any issues with the world
tier automatically going up
bump it down don't worry about it and
then when you get towards the end game
then you start going to build
then you can start pushing that
challenge don't worry as much about the
world tier at first it's not totally
required
should just be a lot of love so shout
out to travis you got the slow-mo rack
slow mo rounds level with the poison all
right all right
yeah man i'm looking forward to it i'm
looking forward to getting into that
getting into those builds messing around
more yeah
i was like it's fun and it's like
believe me going through on other
characters it's a completely different
feel so it's like learning it all over
again
so the freshness is still there and fun
and i'll do a couple characters probably
play through most of them over time
depending on what comes out death loop
we know just got delayed till september
so maze
i think that might be a mass effect
somewhere in there but it's like new
season will be coming so it's like
this next month of april probably still
going to be a good chunk out writers
because i don't think guardian games is
going to be
anything amazing if it's just you not
pumped
you got it i mean i don't expect the
rewards to be big it's like i may grind
for say like a catalyst or something
but i'm not i'm like it goes on for
three weeks and i'm not gonna put three
weeks into it is all so that's more it i
think than anything
i wish you yeah they they go ahead and
do something spectacular to get me to
log in
so stay tuned for next week when we talk
about the preview for guardian games
that i'm sure we're going to get in the
12 next thursday because it comes out
the week after
i gotta send a shout out to my hunters
can y'all please make guardian games
more hunter friendly
as a warlock i felt that they got the
short edge of the stick with the
requirements
so can we please not have this titan
friendly
event i think i said it's a class
based so shout out to a little spoiler
heads up class-based
playlist activities so like you you
might cuban for a strike playlist it's
all titans you might or all hunters or
all warlocks
i don't know how oh it's going to
function per se but it is going to be
pretty specific to your class i think i
don't know all the details i haven't
looked in too much
you know you can't be rigging the votes
man there you go
yeah get that in love you try to bribe
the kid
yeah so if you didn't get air apparent
that's supposed to be coming back
potentially a catalyst for it as well
this time around
i don't know what the catalyst is going
to do because it literally already pops
a shield and spins
so i'm not entirely sure what else maybe
faster up time for the shield
bigger clip or something
interesting did someone just spill news
if you made it to this far in the
podcast you're a destiny fanatic anyway
so you're probably not too worried about
spoilers and you probably already looked
them up yourself trams come on
is that data
exclusive
the the increased fire rate oh
okay and i work i put that refills
refills the ammo on shield break
could be it yeah we'll see um but yeah
so next week we'll probably get a
preview for that
they'll be probably playing some
outriders in the middle as you know out
i still will probably start peppering
and stuff for me it's like i think now
on kind of like my midweek stuff
might be like wednesday might be like
ori too like that's
that's where i'll probably start
peppering some of those in so
uh but yeah i think that's all we got
for the week we kind of
beat both of the games to death this
morning um
having a lot of fun i can say it's like
i know i i ragged really hard on the
changes to the in-game stuff
you'll never even know this is even a
thing when you play through the story
so go through have fun with some mess
with the mods mess with the builds
it was like a couple specific builds got
hit but if you were like running a
freeze build for a technomancer i don't
even know if you'd know this happened
right so there's a lot of the game
that's still totally fine and crazy fun
don't get me wrong
having a blast it's just some choices as
you said i'm watching and i'm
and i'm just cautious yeah we're just
we're just looking at you because we
want
listen it comes from a place of love we
want these games to succeed
and we want them to not make the
mistakes of their
failed predecessors and that that's
where that's where i was coming from
shout out to my man neil mental was in
here shout out man slow mo backslap
those are division guys so when they
saw that note that early and then
you know they saw that so early like
they were just like yo
just be careful people can fly come on
now you know i'm saying let them have
fun
and we'll see you know hopefully like i
said it's not any patterns could be
something that's early they wanted to
get
ahead of okay cool but let us have fun
because that's
why we're enjoying the game that's why
we we're loving the craziness
the fun combinations and just the the
micro the minutia the micro management
is just so much fun
and that people like to go crazy it
feels good you're like yo this build i
mean i just
wrecked that boss like you feel like a
beast like it feels awesome and that's
what it is
yep so that's what it is we just we just
want them to succeed so i'm hyped
i'm excited to see where it's going and
it's it's a fun palette
cleanse as a destiny fan i have to admit
it's a fun
palette cleanse just to be able to let
your hair down and don't worry about
someone slapping your wrists or
something like that australian guy's
laughing
it's like no game's perfect but yeah
it's doing enough things right that
other people should notice
right what it did like there are some
quality of life things the customization
the appreciation of the of the players
time right
like the customization of the skill tree
the resets like
all of those things are really mostly
well done not perfect again but ver a
lot of them are very well done
glasses play different early game versus
late game as well so if you're in a
class
if you can find a way to survive or turn
the world tear down later on mods open
the world up that's the best way i can
say it so
and final point please for the love of
god
hey honestly like when that patch comes
there's supposed to be a lot of good
things so give it
give it about a week or so and that's
again like that week or so time to get
those servers right
and that may be one of those things like
that april first date could have been
like hey this is our window we go much
later
you know other things are going to be
there so it's like yeah but yeah
i got to play with my man yeah i want to
play with my man yeah cross play the
fixes
the like multiplayer the stutters bats
coming in that patch they're shooting
weeks a week week and a half that's what
they're saying they're close got the
exact date
it's in the line it's not me no it's
definitely the damn patch notes
that's that was that the the developer
dealer oh okay sorry
you missed me see when we do 101
shout out to ian's time y'all it's that
last word
fitness time we got to get back at that
gym we gotta hit
listen you can't get out to the gym
because the cold restrictions we got you
man my man eat bartus right here
doing these amazing sitters for you
getting everybody
right y'all look at the form yo he
opened up the room like this is gonna be
a full season
of calisthenics so look how he got the
room open for y'all he was ready he was
ready to put y'all through this work and
that pain
look at that pain i meant that that's a
technomancer style sit up
look how he froze look how he froze at
the time
look at look at that techno right there
so we just gotta put a little techno
beat to the back of this while we doing
this get this
get this rocking you know what i said
salute and the face is red yes let's go
what we got oh they got two more
we got to all oh yo let me explain this
is advanced level this is an expedition
style leg raise right see these
full we're embracing the outriders flow
look at that form
look at this look at the synergy the
parallel to the ground
and then back listen this is advanced
level stuff only ibantus can do this
show i'm just explaining y'all right now
this is this is this level to this they
want you to hydrate they want you to
we giving you that exclusive you see
that [ __ ] guy right that phone was
crazy
form's crazy you gave us a superb fart
training
yes keep them clenched keep them
clenched you don't want to do that in
the gym we got to respect the company
friends don't let friends sit up fart
and push up for in the gym
sometimes you can't help those guys
sometimes you gotta let it loose man
no doubt classic flashpoint vibes today
good times good times it was a good one
it was a good one
this is why yo i know you're stupid
you're really stupid you're killing me
uh this has been a blast this morning
guys thank you very much chad for being
here
so many guys gamma popping in irl titan
many guests just stopping by
giving some love new red the regulars
gto
all of you guys this morning i'm
literally just looking at it in here but
dakota
i know so many guys black wings trams
bird bro
trying to give call outs marvel all of
you guys that have been chatty this
morning thank you guys have been lurking
if you've been listening and you're work
morning whatever you got going on thank
you guys very much uh but cog what do
you got
what happened recently any shout outs
you need to give
uh yeah let them know yeah what your
week has been and anything you got
coming up but yeah i wanted you to shout
out what you got
already happened doctor thank you
brother that fun week man what a week
it's been tremendous for iop
you know um obviously the um being
invited to uh ign unlocked again
which is really cool man shout out to
ryan mccaffrey salute everybody that
supported it
and showed love and i seen a couple of
people to see yo i knew him from last
word i was like okay that's what i'm
talking about
dude it was it was humbling it was cool
to see talking about everything that's
going on
you know so uh salute man really really
humbling with people who
value your opinion and once you're back
you know so
salute to that and then secondly
obviously we had a colin moriarty on our
special tuesday yeah so so check that
out iop
and that was cool man some really heart
to heart discussions and stuff like that
touched a lot of subjects a lot what's
going on in the industry really cool
really cool um passionate passionate
discussion so if you get a chance
check that out that's what i love
podcast youtube channel and then lords
of gaming man
moving out here and doing stuff on the
website
and i'm really proud of the guys just
still keeping on we got some stuff
planned with that as well
kind of like some one-on-one uh hit
pieces and stuff like that
i might actually uh might have to
hit you up for something and a little
secret project will talk okay all right
so what you're doing with your
developers
and virtual things when all that's done
i'll see if i can find some time for you
i appreciate you have your people speak
to my people
so everybody back oh yeah shout out this
sunday oh i a little podcast check us
out we're back we're getting two iops
this week
so you had the tuesday with colin we're
gonna have a sunday with uh windows
central's on miles don't yet
i think that's how you pronounce it
french so um yeah check him out he's
really cool
you had jazz on a while ago right yeah a
long time yeah this is this is from the
same camp and
this guy is really cool so sunday 1 p.m
eastern
check us out it'll be cool and of course
you better be checking out the best damn
destiny podcast
that two people are putting on in the
world right now i'm super proud of what
we're doing the last word
just to hear e say all the guests that
we had up until this point
was kind of humbling just to hear it you
know and just to see us go strong and
people i i see more people checking out
the content
and stuff like that it's been it's been
really cool to see humbling to see man
and
i like the fact that the you know the
lunar shooter stuff we're covering
out riders also now that's kind of fun
you know what i'm saying i was excited i
was actually excited like yo
you're more excited to come out right i
mean that's right
i literally did one one quick destiny
video there's not any story changes
happening we got most of the season
i've been yeah short for destiny mostly
hours this week i've been having fun
it's nice it's been a good refreshing
break and these are the times usually
like
if outriders last long enough kind of
gets you a good breath
and you don't jump in like try and burn
too much out at the end a new season of
destiny will feel good
yeah then and that's refreshing these in
its bag is like
took my break fresh content and
especially if we get more story stuff
like this coming up
the drip feed may be like but overall
like that new season's gonna feel really
good especially after break like this
it's gonna feel better
so absolutely so e what you got going i
see those videos going on those
bills going on yeah cc stuff uh yeah i'm
still working on
basically my technomancer's got a lot of
my time gonna try the devastator for a
different feel
um mostly just streaming that probably
gonna work on pepper and some stuff in
uh i know for one of my couple patreons
that i've got uh
ori is definitely high on the list so
that's gonna be probably working in like
variety days maybe it's like a saturday
stream
um see what's up with that but orient
the will of the list the first one is so
good and i think just as a shorter
content we've still got you know this
like outriders is gonna be a big piece
but ori's awesome
um try not to do anything i don't want
to start like death stranding yet
because that's always like
big stuff that like that is like this is
going to be my ex
game for like the next six weeks i don't
want to quite do one of those yet
there's a big stuff that i do want to
play so
there's never enough time um but it's
just trying to figure out the pieces
that fit in the puzzle
so selfishly can i get more um different
outrider builds
videos sir oh yeah yes i would really
appreciate that i will i will send you a
link to one that will have you crack up
now it takes a lot of work to get to
some of the pieces of it
but there's some interesting things
behind it i tried it last night it's
okay
you won't die like if you're leveling
you will not die you're just not gonna
go too well in the expeditions because
you move slowly it's the
gun but it's a really cool it's a cool
minigun build
okay okay and are you going to be
because i know devastating right now so
the focus is devastating are we going to
be getting some devastated content
i mean if i can get there believe me
that might be like how to level up a
devastator
like what especially would be there yeah
so i was like no it's like
i'll still be doing like outright stuff
for a little while like you know content
numbers-wise it may not be
quite as big but it's still like it's
decent so it's like i do want to try and
mix it in just to kind of
spread the love a little bit oh i can't
wait i'm excited
i get to learn more stuff i'm in class
without you teaching me the bills
so yeah for me just yeah stay tuned on
twitch youtube twitter you know where to
follow both and all of us
uh but for this episode 144 this went
longer than i thought it was going to
two and a half later
much less a little preview part of the
stream it's been a long one this morning
but it's been a ton of fun
of course good old flashpoint as you
said two man vibes we're gonna go raid
pigeon he's gonna be on here in like
three weeks or so scott a streamer
um you might have to ask him to
pronounce something once or twice but
yeah
thick accent but hilarious dude so go
hang out in there send him some love but
for this episode
april 9th episode 144 me and my co-host
brother of the best
thank you sir it has been